Okay.
Yeah.
Ah,
birds already got the top off the vodka.
I want to cleanse your,
yeah,
dude,
I'm telling you.
Ready for this?
Yes.
Todd could cleanse.
Well,
it's is clear.
Oh,
it's good for you.
No,
it's clear.
Anything clear?
That's my,
I don't know Joe.
I'm fucking not clear.
Like Tequila.
Tequila is on the cleanse.
It was meth by the way.
It's pretty clear,
right?
Clear good math.
And that's hard to come by these days.
Um,
ever clear.
That's not good for you,
right?
That's clear.
Acid moonshine.
That's clear it.
This is the doing strings.
It's,
it's a different approach to a Clintons.
No,
I talked to you the other day.
I was 55.6.
This is the most hilarious conversation.
Burke calls.
It goes,
I'm cleaning up my life.
That's it.
He goes,
I'm too heavy.
I go,
what are you going to do?
He goes,
no more appetizers.
And he was serious.
I wasn't joking.
Get all serious like appetizers where it's doing yet.
Dude,
I make it rain appetizers.
When I sit down,
I'm like,
I go,
first of all,
every time.
What are your two best appetizers?
And they're like,
Yup,
I go,
we want those good.
Why not?
Right.
Okay,
well a little taster,
right?
Here's where I really got and here's where the weight gain really came on.
Anyone that really that's been working with me knows this.
I owed her two meals.
I order two meals cause I like to eat like a king.
I'm not paying for it,
but so like you're not paying for it and that work's paying for it.
It's Oh,
creator.
So you're assuming like all your meat,
that's how much you work,
man.
You work so much.
Most of your meals are paid for.
I haven't had,
I haven't paid for a meal in 11 months.
That's so crazy.
I've been on the road straight for 11 fucking months.
Dude.
Nobody I know travels as much as you other than Bordain maybe.
He's pretty close.
He's travels a fucking Dick load and he goes to like all over the mirror.
Well,
he goes a horrible places that are like really scary.
I think that's the reason he left the travel channel is that they wouldn't let
them go to those places.
I don't know.
No,
no,
no.
I was pretty certain.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause uh,
cause CNN has a different set of insurance and travel channel's insurance
doesn't cover like they're like dangerous skateboard shipping type shit.
It doesn't cover it pretty much your own insurance.
Almost his last episode,
he was in the Congo.
I haven't watched it yet,
but I saw the Congo and I was way too hard to watch it.
I was like,
no,
don't,
can't do it.
No.
I did a Montana episode with him a couple of weeks ago.
Yeah,
we camped out too.
We did the full Montana experience,
went pheasant hunting and then we camped out.
Hung out by the fire,
got lit up.
It was fun.
So wait,
does he drink camping?
Oh yeah.
We went hard.
We weren't hard boozing.
We'd everything.
We went hard.
Anthony Bordain to not fuck around.
You know what's really incredible?
That guy's addicted to Jujitsu.
Yeah.
90% of what he was talking about,
he just wanted to talk
about Jujitsu.
He started when he was like 58 or 57 years old.
Now he's 59 and he just everyday trains.
He trains when he's on the road,
he goes to these places like Bozeman,
Montana,
and he finds like a local group of guys and he goes and rolls at these guys.
He's a madman.
A wife.
Get him into it.
Yeah.
His wife is super into it.
Super into it.
She's uh,
she's constantly training.
Like I think she trains like twice a day,
every day.
Wow.
Now that's good for him.
And he looks,
he looks good.
It doesn't look like a,
he doesn't look like the way he should look.
He's one of the clearings.
And you're in the mine.
Yeah.
He looks a lot better than he looked just a few years ago.
Smoking cigarettes.
No,
no.
He stopped when his daughter was born.
Wow.
Except for the occasional one.
He'll cheat.
You know,
I think,
but uh,
I don't even think he does that anymore.
And now that he's doing Jujitsu,
I'm sure he does it.
You know,
what happens with the Jujitsu world with the lifestyle is you get those become
your new friends.
Like those become like it and it becomes like a Jujitsu family and like they
understand you more than other people understand you because they've choked you,
you know,
and you've,
you've gone to,
to battle together an intimacy when someone chokes you out.
Like a bizarre,
like I held you in my hand.
Yeah.
I could've let go.
You and I decided to keep you.
Yeah,
definitely.
There's definitely something there.
And then it also like makes regular life seemed kind of boring,
you know,
so they'd just get engulfed into that world and some people they wind up doing
that to the point of that becomes their job.
They ended up teaching it.
I know a lot of people have left lucrative careers because they decided they
wanted to start teaching Jujitsu.
Yeah.
And they just got into it a lot.
They were doing it,
they started teaching private lessons and then they just downsized and started
doing Jujitsu.
They're like,
this is just so much more fun than being some guy trying to climb the corporate
ladder.
Is there,
um,
I know that they,
like most martial arts,
there's like a spiritual message.
Is there any like kind of spiritual guidelines through Jujitsu?
Well,
there are in different schools,
you know,
depending on who's teaching you and how they,
how they approach it.
But there's as overall in the art of Jujitsu,
and I call it an art because it really is an art.
It's like there's it's techniques and it's,
it's a martial art.
It's the most,
most Marshall or the most art of martial arts in my opinion,
and my opinion because it's the most open to creativity.
Like guys like Eddie Bravo is the best example of that because he's such a
creative guy.
He's invented so many moves,
so many transitions and pathways and named them and they're really unique.
So if like your role with him,
he literally don't know what he's doing.
If you roll with the standard Jujitsu Guy,
even if you're really good,
like if there's like there's certain guys like a Hicks and Gracie for example,
who does the basics,
all of the basics of Jujitsu,
but does them to a level of mastery that you cannot comprehend until he trained
with him and you,
when you train with him,
you would just go,
all that other stuff is nonsense.
You just need straight Jujitsu,
you know,
from the mothership,
from Eylea Gracie and Carlos Gracie,
that's all you need.
Just razor sharp.
That shit.
Hodra Gracie is like that hens,
those like that.
They,
they mostly just do the basics but to a level of mastery that's incomprehensible
to the average person.
But then there's a bunch of guys that are super creative.
Like Jeff Glover,
the guy that we were talking about the other day,
he's one of them.
Bravo.
Eddie Bravo is one of them,
of course.
And there's a bunch of other guys out there too.
Um,
Eddie Cummins,
who's a student of this guy.
Um,
John Danaher who's probably the most creative of all the,
the teachers or one of the most creative next to Eddie.
Um,
and he's like got this crazy leg lock game that they're all learning so they're
all learning this like super complicated leg lock came from this guy who was
like a philosophy phd major.
That's what he was doing.
He was like studying philosophy and working as a bouncer and he got into Jujitsu
because he wanted to learn how to defend themselves cause all these fights would
happen when people are drunk.
And then he just became obsessed with Jujitsu and now he's like one of the most
sought after Jiu Jitsu coaches in the world.
Like George Saint Pierre,
you still use him and he teaches at Henzel Gracie academy in New York.
So it's like there's like this real underground like it's,
it's not what everybody thinks it is.
People think of it as being like meatheads and like these like really muscled up
do's with tattoos on their necks.
It's not,
there's a lot of those guys in there too,
but what it really is,
is this crazy problem solving game that's going on that everybody's playing with
their body.
It's going to sound like a really silly question,
but if we give you,
if you,
if say Eddie Bravo,
say you picked a fight with Eddie Bravo and he was forced to kick your ass.
Would there be at some point when you woke up the next day that you'd remember
something he did to you artistically and be like,
damn,
I was beautiful.
Well yeah,
we'll,
we spar.
If we would spar,
Eddie would do shit to me and I would go,
what?
What'd you do?
How'd you set that up?
What did I do wrong?
And like he's always teaching like he doesn't hide anything from students.
Yeah.
He's always trying to get them so that they tap him.
Like he gets tapped by students,
but he considers it a good thing.
It's like I taught this guy so well that he can get me there.
That you need that if you don't have that,
it's like,
don't you agree that as standup comedians we need to be around killers?
Like you need to be around Diaz.
He need to be around guys like Burt,
like when you're around all these killers,
it makes you up your game.
I told you that the day after we were all at the comedy store,
uh,
and you had the joke about,
Bruce Jenner,
the gargoyle and I'm fucking howling in the back and I,
and I'm,
I don't know if I told you this part,
but I will tell you right now,
and then I went up in between you,
amber.
Amber went up after me and to seamlessly destroyed and then you went up into the
seamlessly destroyed after him and I got,
I woke up the next morning.
I totally Anna,
so I'm fucking bombed.
I'm not,
I'm not like,
I'm not writing the way these guys were writing.
Like I'm,
I feel like I'm,
I'm slow.
I'm not,
I feel clumsy on stage.
I feel like,
I feel like I should.
I,
and then Leann was like,
hold on,
hold on.
You're talking about Joe and bill,
two of the best comedians in the world,
so don't hold to that standard,
but use that.
Use that inspiration by watching the bests to say to yourself,
well fuck,
I can be better.
That's if that's what you're saying.
I always feel like that he always got to feel like you could be better.
Right?
I mean I always do I those low level cons who come out of a club and they're
like,
well just look that room.
I'll fucking fire.
And you're like,
I don't know what fight you saw but I saw you get kind of fucking up against the
ropes like New York is was when I was there.
It was filled with that.
Guys that walk out fucking destroyed that shit in the beginning.
I think that's like a defense mechanism that guys put on.
If you talk to most comics,
most comics are not happy with their act.
Do you think seriously good people that are good?
Yeah.
It was always like these moments where you're like,
God,
I gotta fix this.
I've got to tighten that up.
I got gotta.
It's the guys that are like super confident about my act.
Perfect right now.
Your ex dog shit,
you know that's like,
it's just a,
there's a like a high level of scrutiny that you have to give yourself and give
what you're doing and you know,
it does,
it's like this is a lot of bits that just don't ever work.
They just know you got to eventually get a thought,
throw them in the garbage,
they just don't like,
you're like,
God damn it.
There's something in here and you just hammer at it and trying to turn into a
sword.
But nope,
it's just a ladle.
It's a ladle.
It's gonna stay a ladle.
It just never works.
It just stupid thing that you very rarely use and it's just like might've worked
a couple of times on stage in certain places,
but it's just can't figure out the transition.
And then there's other bits that you like.
You Pilfer you take chunks of them and you create other bits with them and it
turns out that there are better mine than they are like an entity.
They're better for like mining ideas.
That's how that happens all the time.
We have a bit and you're into the bit,
but it turns out the,
the best part about it is like a side thing,
you know,
like a little side path that you take while you're creating it.
Yeah.
I like it more than I've ever liked.
It fed up more than ever.
It's so much fun man.
You know,
especially like right now because uh,
is a year after my last special and I have like a full set now and now I'm just
trying to make it good and trying to add to it and cut away from it.
But it's like I am working with,
you know,
a full hour,
20 minutes of new stuff so it's all,
I pretty much have what I need to turn into like a weapon now.
Now I have to like hone it and sharpen it.
It's super exciting man.
Cause it's nerve racking and you know,
and you're doing a lot of sets and you're fucking around in different places and
it's just never been more excited about it.
So much fun.
I'm the,
not the opposite of you,
but like I get,
I have a hard time.
I,
I like the fucking of creativity.
I like to fucking of impulse.
I don't like to,
I don't like to be in a relationship with creativity.
She's like,
I don't,
I'm not,
I don't want to meet,
create,
I like the moment where you get an idea,
you meet it at the bar and you fucking take it home and you fuck it up against a
wall and then you walk out and you're like,
I'll never call that idea again.
I love that.
Like,
so you mean like in the moment,
like on a show on improvisation?
Is that what you mean?
Yeah.
I love when you come up with an idea and I,
and I walk away.
I love that guy.
Almost like,
I used to call,
used to call it the angel share of like it wasn't a bit,
it was just happened or you or,
or what happens to me.
A lot of times I'll come up with a bit and I'll kind of Ha I'll fuck it one
night.
I won't make a relationship out of it and then I'll just use it and I'd be like,
okay,
I'm not going to,
I don't wanna fuck with that.
I'm bored like I want to do,
I want the new next thing I'm a,
I'm a commitment phobe with material.
Like I run a tear through material of so quickly that I just go like,
and maybe it's because it's not that good or maybe it's because I'm not focusing
on it,
but I don't really have a lot of the passion of focus on it and literally toil
with a bit.
Like I get really kind of disconnected sometimes on stage,
like,
well I told him she's throwing out and I'm a second car.
Second,
I say when I was 22 years old,
I fucking feel a weight on my shoulders.
Like,
fuck,
this is 12 minutes.
We were talking about this the other day.
Like you should just get that on a video,
get that and put it on Netflix thing or something and then just release it so
you don't have to do it anymore.
Yeah,
I've were were negotiated in that.
I would put would you,
what are you talking about?
I brought up and if you do that man,
like then like maybe a year from now,
so going to last week,
tell him and I'll be inspired.
It'll still be fun.
But yeah,
you could tell a story.
Even a great story like that story,
you can tell it too many times and just just call it goes away from you.
It doesn't mean anything and noises.
It's like,
you know,
like they would sell if you ever say fuck around your grandma,
it's like Whoa,
it sounds so harsh.
You know,
like Oh my God,
you know?
But if you say fuck to us,
we say fuck around each other.
So often it's just like the or end or,
but it's just normal cause no unusual registration of it,
you know?
I think that's the same thing with story.
If you tell a story so much that doesn't,
it doesn't register anymore.
Even though if you heard it for the first time,
you'd be like,
why?
Like the first time you told me that story,
I was like,
what?
What the fuck he doing?
No,
it's just,
it's filled with,
no,
it's a chaos filled story.
It's an awesome story.
So,
but if you,
you know,
you fucking too many times.
Yeah,
that's where I'm at right now.
Get bored.
Right?
It's a Chechen whore and a fucking 10 fucking miners are just running trains on
it to cigarette breath.
Come on,
you went to fuck when the month time come on the machine and you're show me,
they'll show me you have to change the oil.
There is a great moment though when you tell that story and I have no passionate
about telling it but I tell it and then this,
this like a couple that it just doesn't seem like they'd ever liked me.
Just come out there like that was fucking amazing.
And you're like,
you forget.
Exactly.
Daniel Thomas told me this.
He goes,
you have no idea how many people don't know who you are.
Like concept of like you think everyone's heard the story.
Everyone's heard the story.
I would say at least,
at least 80% of every room I sell out or I sell or I sell,
you know,
in the club hasn't heard of me,
hasn't heard that story.
At least live you will.
You've got to think about how many people there are to listen to nowadays too.
You know,
like for them to know,
even if they catch one of your podcasts,
like you've been on this pockets walk six,
seven times,
something like that.
If they catch one of them,
it might not
have them [inaudible] machine store in it.
Oh.
So they might think you're the best and they don't even know that story.
I uh,
I've met a guy on a plane going to Japan who's a fucking massive failure.
He had the shirt on and I,
this is how fucking disconnected I am with life.
Sometimes I just like see the Jerry shirt.
I'm like,
I'll walk by him slow and he'll be like June.
Like in my head I really thought that that's ego,
whatever.
I'll be honest.
I make eye contact with the guy and the guy who was high and I was like,
hey,
you look like a bear when the big gay bear
13 hour flight.
I'm like,
Hey.
He's like,
Hey,
and then I'll be like,
and then I did it like twice,
like I water.
I was like,
wait,
maybe I,
maybe I just got to do my laugh.
I don't know.
Like
in my head I'm like,
I'm like,
this is super drunk.
I'll fucking drunk Joe.
And so it makes you do my labs.
So then it finally I got a third walk by,
I'm like,
uh,
Amen.
Rogan experience.
And he's like,
fuck yeah man.
And I was like,
Yo.
He was like,
you listen to it.
Yeah,
I have.
And in my head I was like,
I gotta be honest.
I have like fucking five back loaded for this flight.
And I was like,
yeah,
which ones do you have loaded?
And I forget what we talked about that she just said,
you should get Bert Kreischer.
He's amazing.
Do you know who Burt Christ's words?
You don't leave the machine.
It's the best story ever.
Did you gotta to turn it on it?
So,
uh,
and then I finally said to him,
I was like,
I've,
I've been on the podcast.
And he was like,
really?
Who are you?
I said,
Bert cry.
She was like,
oh,
cool.
He's like,
I don't get to everyone.
I'm really into the mixed martial artists.
I was like,
oh,
cool.
And so,
and then I was like,
well,
I'll tell you who you should listen to.
And then I was like,
have you listened to Dunkin or Joey or Ari?
And he was like,
I've heard already.
I know Joey.
I don't know dunk.
Like he just was like,
he was a mixed martial artist fan and he was ripped to what is dictates.
Likes.
Yeah.
Salty.
It was a flight to Japan.
I put with Sabi on it.
Ooh,
wow.
Someone's done that.
Oh,
I guarantee you,
I'm sure it's coated in Wasabi.
It's definitely happened after listening.
Then humiliation.
Oh yeah.
Not Bizarre.
I fucking couldn't turn it off.
That was the shortest podcasts where we did,
it was like an hour.
She's very nice.
It wasn't her fault.
Choosy humiliate tricks.
Yeah.
I know very well known.
One of those where she likes steps on the guys balls with high heels.
Doesn't do that.
She doesn't do anything in person.
Oh she does it all over the Internet and all over the phone and all over like
she sends them things and they like they pay for a poop and her fingernails and
shit like dirty stinky,
stinky socks and stuff.
They pay for underwear.
[inaudible] underwear one.
Well there's all sorts of weird shit too.
Like they'll film themselves doing awful things like getting fucked by guys and
they send it to her and then she holds it and she threatens to blackmail them
and then they get suicidal but they want this,
they request this like she would never release it.
It's really interesting.
She's very smart
and she was a very nice person.
She like didn't seem like the type of person that would do that.
She's very intelligent,
like you have a great conversation with her.
Joe's a,
it was an interesting,
it was interesting.
The thing that she said that was interesting to me was an eye for hurt bird.
I was with a dominatrix for a day,
so I was like full blown all with a dominatrix.
And what was really fascinating is they said something about that first sexual
experience you have,
it sets an imprint for who you're going to be sexually.
Yeah.
And I remember the first thing I ever fucking saw was uh,
on Fletcher Avenue Ne,
this pizza shop is old news stand in.
My sister picked up a magazine that was bondage and showed it to me and was
like,
like fucking full blown bondage.
And I was like,
what?
I was like maybe first grade.
I was like,
what the fuck?
When I went to this dominatrix in like 19,
no 2001 is when I went and did an episode.
She said,
uh,
she check out some of my stuff.
We're just bullshitting mistress Isabella.
Ari had her own as podcast too.
He's like,
you just turn it on someone and stuff and gave me a bunch of videos and I put in
one and dude,
one thing,
just like fucking like the rubber gloves up to the shoulders with the boost Da.
And I was literally,
it brought me back to that point and I had this fucking,
it's like rediscovering like shit.
Like I was like,
holy fuck.
Really?
Oh,
so it imprinted in you during that formative age.
So you've had an actual experience with angel.
You again,
just please,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna say six.
I'm going to have probably first grade before first grade around first grade.
When was it that you saw it again?
28 years old.
Wow.
So 22 years later or something like
22 years later.
And I'm,
by the way,
I'd never been tied up.
I never tied up a girl I'd never been in,
but I'd never,
I'd never done any of that.
She had never been leather or like,
or like never been leather,
like been leathered up or their depth.
Yeah,
no,
you know,
like I never been any,
I'm like a meat and potatoes fucker.
Like I go in,
I have sex,
maybe a couple of positions,
but that's it.
And uh,
and then I saw this and I was like,
it fucking hit a switch.
And I was like,
what the fuck?
But you liked it.
I liked it.
I thought it was hot.
Like you've ever looked at like little Mrs. Yeah,
she knows I had Mr Mistresses,
Isabel at my house.
I wish my wife would get into that.
Not Interested in the whole lesson.
Taste with kids,
do not want to get tied up.
That's just a fact.
Fucking and not at all.
What happened?
They used to love that shit because now they're,
they're a mom.
There's something that happens.
It switches.
It's very hard to describe.
Um,
I think you know a little bit of it because you're a dad and when you become a
dad,
you switch from just being a guide with dad and it's,
it's a very real switch,
but I don't think it's nearly as gigantic as the switch that goes off inside of
a woman when she actually grows the baby in her body and then gives birth to it
and then is insanely responsible for that baby.
And they loved them to a level that like you,
you compare the way you love your kids to the way someone says,
Oh my God,
I love cat.
You like,
you don't even know what the fuck love is.
You think a cat is like,
I can love a cat openly and pure porch.
Shut the fuck up.
Shut up.
If you had a kid it would be different.
Yeah,
there's,
there's an intense,
and I don't even necessarily say that this is like a moral choice that you make
that it's different.
I think there's some insane biological switches that go off that are undeniable.
You know,
there's this connection between oxytocin and kids and that you look at the kids
and you,
your brain produces oxytocin,
which is just love feeling.
There's like all sorts of weird shit that goes on.
I think that for a woman and not all women,
because there's women that have that do porn,
that have babies,
they have families and they have,
they,
you know,
they've given birth and then they go and just get gang bang by giant dicks and
they love it.
They love it.
You think they love it?
I don't know.
They say they love it.
I have no reason to believe they're lying and I don't want to ruin it.
I don't know.
They say they love it.
I think there's a lot of different people in the world,
man.
Think about a guy like you and some,
some guy who's like really into accounting.
You know there's gotta be someone out there that enjoy is doing people's books.
There's gotta be some noise and try it.
There's gotta be someone out there that does that.
That's a real person.
So if this is a real person,
I think of course he's a real person wants to pay for Sierra Lynch's shit or you
know,
some real person who can do stand up comedy like so people are fucking weird.
We vary so much.
I mean that's why there's so many different types of music and so many different
types of movies and just human beings are fucking very strange.
But one big thing that does happen with a lot of them is that they have kids and
they change.
Fucking really changed.
Like I would fucking night and day,
I don't even know the guy was before trying to get lap dances and like undo my
zipper with your butt cheeks.
That kinda guy.
Right.
I don't even fucking know that guy anymore.
I know that guy.
We've been drunk with that guy.
Produce.
He'd do them next time we get drunk.
We good.
Hey Bert,
this is your other Bert.
This is the original Bert.
He's still here.
He's just a dormant like some alien virus.
I always think if someone videotaped me jerking off it will go.
But like,
you know,
like those,
uh,
the I things and the Max,
I was like,
someone's gotta be able to get in there already have made sure that you have,
and if they've done that,
I'm just putting out the numbers of the honeypot.
I gotta be met folded in there somewhere.
You just have to go all in.
I've found and let get her dad and notice my light was on.
And then I was like frantically looking through all my programs to see which one
was using my webcam.
None of them were.
And now I'm like,
all right.
You know what,
how long has this been going on?
I've just straight been masturbating for,
Geez,
even for like a long time.
You just have to accept it that they've seen you come many times.
It's probably fun
for them.
Imagine be able to hack into your laptop and watch the machine shirk off criss
cross apple sauce on a bed
thinking with the toes.
No pausing in between jerkiness off your toes every fucking time.
Like I'm not sure if I want to know this.
I'll tell Ya.
Criss Cross applesauce on a mattress.
That's how you do it.
Yeah.
You always sit criss criss cross apple.
Yo,
you ever hear her bosses joke about sitting Indian style?
No.
When I was in first grade,
the teacher told me and sit Indian style.
So I got drunk and laid the curb fucking loverage balls for the uninitiated.
What exactly is criss cross applesauce sitting with your legs?
Cause sitting Indian style.
It was what we call it as kids.
And so then uh,
and then uh,
why don't you remember that?
What do you mean by do I remember that?
Because he has kids.
Apple sauce.
Oh cause I have kids.
You can't say,
can't say like Indian style.
Well yeah,
he can say said it didn't trouble.
Now,
you can't say gypped.
You can't say like chipped is Gypsies.
Yeah.
And they're fucking rain in La.
They are.
Oh God,
yeah man.
Caravans.
Fucking know they're,
they're like these Russian gypsies like lower these Ukrainian gypsies live in
there and you cannot get them to fucking obey traffic laws at all.
Yeah.
Do I do like a safety valve for our school?
They'll come rolling in just in just food and just don't give a fuck about
anyone and you,
you can't tell them anything.
They just start fucking yell at you and literally don't give up the side.
Your daughter's school.
Both of my daughters school,
I ran into a black security guard.
I wanted to go to be black because he fucking was and so and so because he
wouldn't say I ran into a white security guard.
Yeah,
I wouldn't,
I just say I ran into a security guard.
He was Mexican.
I rarely say Mexican cause cause I'm about to do his accent.
So I would,
I'd definitely be like,
so he just goes,
man,
these motherfuckers don't listen to shit.
I ain't racist or nothing but fuck,
fuck these watching all the blockers.
And I was like,
really?
I was like I but I get it man.
We come from much harsher,
harsher place.
A place where you had to fight for fucking toilet paper and then you come here
and you're like soft.
Oh everyone's soft.
Soft little holes in our top of our heads.
Still babies and the rest is just fucking just fuck these red lights.
Red Lights.
Yeah.
The word Gyp is a weird one because I never even knew what that mean Matt until
I realized like Oh like a decade ago.
Oh yeah.
Gypsy.
Oh you know the end got lit up for saying one cotton picking minute.
Wait one wait one cotton picking minute.
What?
Right.
Yup.
Cause I just pick cotton.
No hold on.
Who,
who did this?
Just a mom.
Mom.
Overly politically correct mam.
Just excuse me.
I'd appreciate if you didn't use that kind of language lambs.
Like wait hold on.
We were talking about cause like there's things where we said when kids like you
call people ninnies well I think that what's [inaudible] and then he is a,
I think it's a derivative of picking any,
which is a derivative of a young black kid
from islands.
So,
but we got called ninnies all growing up and I still send any,
I didn't know that one.
And so Leanne was like calm pig a minute and they're like cotton picking minute.
It has to do something with black people and Lance like,
and by the way,
lance was saying that her whole life and never,
and she and my wife's a redneck,
but it never heard that phrase.
And like her new,
the definition just knew that was a phrase.
So we looked it up.
It turns out a cotton picking minute has nothing to do with race.
It has to do with the fact that cotton is the most tedious crop to pick in the
world.
So if you picked cotton for one minute,
it would feel like a year.
So yes.
When you say,
wait,
what cotton picking minute.
It says wait a little longer than a minute.
Wait one,
wait a long fucking minute.
And so,
but the menu I,
everyone's so quick to be up and fucking outraged.
Well they just looking for an opportunity to be outreach.
I can't imagine that she was actually upset at someone saying one cotton picking
minute.
Yeah.
Oh,
I can't imagine that.
That's dumb.
It's not just dumb.
It's,
it's a sign of the times we live in this time where there's a bunch of people
out there that think they're doing good,
that they're good people because the call people out and they shame people.
You know,
it's,
it's so arbitrary.
What you decide is negative and what other people,
it's all about intent.
Right.
And when you say one cotton picking minute or hold off,
fuck his thinking about racism.
Who's thinking a racist thought?
When you say that,
it's just a nice way saying one motherfucking minute is what it is.
Yeah.
That check was the racist for even putting the two together with that kind of,
she's just a dummy.
There's a lot of them out there.
There's a lot of politically correct dummies.
Like here's,
here's one that's super common that everybody wants to use.
You know the term faggot is a terrible term to use for gay folk ea.
It's okay though.
This terrible term,
right?
I'm going to have to say that that has,
that has backfired because that word is now age,
like a fine wine.
So beautiful.
We were throwing around way too much as kids and now you only hear it all
special occasions and so you're just saying that caught me so fucking old guard.
I was like,
fuck man.
I'm in hindsight,
the machine story and I'm making a comeback,
but two to call someone that for being gay is a terrible thing to do,
right?
It is a slur.
It's a terrible thing to do.
But to call someone that for being just a pussy is what we always did as kids.
Well,
we can't do that anymore because it's so problematic.
It's too connected with that other word.
But one of the things that drives me crazy is when they,
you know,
what does the ed to Ma Entomology,
what's the word?
Etymology.
Right.
When the,
the,
the history of the origins of the word,
they always like to say that it's about a bundle of wood because these to light
gay people on fire,
that was on Louis show,
he repeated this false myth.
That's not what it meant.
A bundle of wood meant you were,
when they called you,
it was all,
it was like a burden.
Some woman,
that's the way they described it,
like a bundle of woods,
like something you got to carry.
That was a really awkward and a pain the ass.
So that
was a faggot of wood.
So when you were acting like of like a pain in the ass woman,
like you would be a Faggot,
you'd be a bundle of wood.
That's such a pain to carry around.
You'd be awkward and annoying.
That's the origins of the word.
So how did it get connected to gay people?
It sounds great that it was because these to light people on fire.
Oh my God,
you're a victim.
Yes,
I am.
So don't use that word again.
So full people tied and sure people have definitely died from being gay,
but that's not the origins of that word.
That's not like the used to be angry.
It's not like the whole world was lightened gay people on fire one point like it
was a sport so much that it became a name.
You connected them,
which is called gay people.
Kerosene.
No,
that's not true.
That's not what it was.
It was a bundle of wood was also like a burden.
Some woman,
that's the way they used to describe it.
You can like,
you can look up the origins of the word.
That makes me feel so much more sense for using it as kids.
When you called your friend a bundle,
a burdensome burdens and woman.
Yeah.
He called him taking forever.
You faggot.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Or You could stop crying,
faggot.
Like that's,
that's has nothing to do with homosexuality.
The,
the homosexuality aspect of it was calling someone that if they're gay as a slur
because if you think of like the stereotypical gay man like that gets mocked,
it's like,
oh my God,
you know that like really femme and feminine,
which would be like a burdensome woman,
so that's why they would call those gay guys that slur.
Holy Shit Man.
West Hollywood.
It's like a faggot of gaze,
right?
A bundle of gays.
Yes.
If you want to use it for the original word that we can start dropping that in
any grouping out,
things will take a of carrots.
It became a cigarette.
I'm not butchering that.
Right.
Go look that up.
Make sure I'm not butchering that.
The 99% sure I'm not,
but there's also some of they're a fag became a cigarette and that was a big one
in England.
Like in England,
they still say that can I call up a fag and they do that to each other and it
has no,
no context is nothing gay about it at all.
It's like their word for that.
It's just,
you know,
it's different.
Like fanny for them is a vagina.
So if you have a fanny pack,
I wear a fanny pack.
They mock me hardcore.
You,
you have a vagina pack.
I know what you're saying.
You have a vagina pack.
That's amazing that they say,
do you know what you're saying?
Yeah.
They clearly,
any pack.
Yeah,
no,
no.
It's bumbag has,
so they call him over there.
They call them bum bags.
But what is the real problem with all this stuff is these forbidden words,
taboo words.
His words not aren't what's important.
It's intent.
And if you go around policing the world and stopping words from being used,
you don't change the People's intent.
You don't do anything but be annoying.
That's all you're doing.
You're being an annoying person.
Who is the voice of moral outrage?
Excuse me.
I would appreciate it if you didn't say cotton picking mirror because you know
that black people
you white privilege to us.
How you see the black people pay car.
Do you know?
You're saying,
do you know what you're saying?
Who fucking racist?
Oh my God,
you're a racist.
I'm going to shame you.
I'm going to blog and they run home to their Tumblr account and blog about your
wife and lie about it.
Oh yeah.
Exaggerate.
Everybody's a fucking victim today.
It's just exaggerate to such an extreme extent.
It's like,
it's so tiresome.
It's like stop.
And the reason why they do it is because he gets attention.
It gets attention.
That will a woman now your wife had to talk to that woman.
What?
And your wife had to defend herself.
Me Ha racist.
And then women's.
I can,
oh,
my wife's one of those people,
like I think of the rate of Formula One in Britain.
Which one?
There's a guy who were informing the one in Britain that got caught in this like
sex scheme.
The sex thing.
Your wife's a pimp?
No,
no,
no.
It's a,
I read a book on shame,
on public shaming,
and there's all these examples and there's just one guy whose dad was a famous
Nazi,
like a Nazi sympathizer.
And then he got caught in these s and m things where it looked like he was a
Nazi and it was like the people,
we're going to fucking slam him.
And it said in the book,
the only way to get through public shaming is to not give a fuck about the
shaming.
Like if you're,
if you don't,
if you're like,
you can't,
shame me,
cause I don't give a fuck
funny with this Charlie Sheen story,
because that's how Charlie Sheen got through everything up until now,
not giving a fuck up until suck in a deck.
And then it's like,
hey,
whoa,
whoa.
I'll give you money.
So we did some dude's Dick allegedly video.
You're getting everything.
Third,
fourth hand.
Who the fuck knows what really happened?
Allegedly?
There's a video.
I don't know.
I haven't seen it.
But the point being,
he said he always owned up to everything he did up until this,
everything he did up until this was like,
who gives a fuck all?
Well that's me.
Tiger blood winning,
you know,
quote unquote.
Now,
now you know,
I mean he went on Matt Lauer's that what it was and said that he had HIV,
but you know what?
HIV is a weird one dude,
because medication that they have today is so effective.
You take HIV medication and it doesn't even show up in your blood.
I'd rather have that than Hep c.
Oh my God,
there's so many dish.
It's got this stigma attached to it.
Right.
But there's so many diseases that kill people that are quicker than that.
Like women die from HPV,
which is like super common,
but we want to pop Loma virus.
Yeah.
Women get cancer from that.
They can get cancer from that and they can die from that.
That's way more common than a guy with HIV in the western world who finds out
about it,
gets diagnosed and started taking medication way more common for a woman to die
from that than it is for the guy to die from the HIV in 2015 2015 is an amazing
time to have HIV.
You want to go get it?
Go get it.
You want it.
It's like they've,
they don't have it licked.
And the point where they work,
where they have an injection that they can give you the cures it,
but they do have medication that make it undetectable.
The him not telling the girls though.
Do you think that's a,
I mean,
that's pretty fucked up,
right?
That's,
that's prison time.
Um,
it's definitely not nice.
Definitely.
I just feel like,
I mean,
I had to do the triangle,
like,
oh shit.
Did I sleep with somebody that slept with somebody that might have slept with
him?
You know,
I it,
I don't think you can get it that way.
There's very little evidence that a man can get it through normal heterosexual
intercourse,
herpes outbreak and or period.
By the way,
I've been saying this for fucking years.
It's not politically correct to say,
but there's very little evidence.
Here's the deal.
If you could,
if it was easy to get.
I'm not saying it's impossible to get because I'm obviously not a doctor and an
idiot,
but I think if it was,
if it was possible or easy to get Jesus Christ,
everybody would have it.
Jeremy would it?
Well,
that's what everybody was worried about in the 1990s when,
when AIDS started the it's rampant rage through the,
the public eye.
Everybody was scared that everybody was going to have it.
I had my first AIDS test and 92 it was an HIV test,
I guess.
Uh,
I was getting a insurance and I had to get it an aids test.
I was like,
oh my God.
It was fucking terrified.
Terrified,
terrified.
And when it came back clean,
I was like,
yes,
because you don't know.
I think all the time she got drunk and didn't use a condom.
And who knows what that girl had and who knows what.
It's just like there's no,
if,
if it really was something that normal heterosexual men got through normal
intercourse.
The way it's been described to me by medical professionals,
obviously not by knuckleheads on the Internet was it,
it's just really difficult to get that because a man is injecting his dick
inside of a girl and coming and a girl,
a woman's vagina on the other hand is an excellent candidate for reception
because it's moist in there.
It's essentially open tissue.
You know,
you,
you can,
it's like,
that's why like some girls take drugs that way.
That's why people take drugs ain't only too,
while you take like an anal suppository,
like dudes to take ecstasy Annaly that take an ecstasy pill and stuff it up
their ass and it'll melt down,
break down and get into their bloodstream.
Yeah.
People to a herpes,
a little drunk tea and tea drinking chill.
You can kill you cause it goes through right into your blood.
Yeah.
That's real dangerous man.
Because it's not going through your stomach.
You can get fucked up from putting like alcohol,
like vodka,
vodka up your asshole tampons.
Right.
And Vodka,
tampons,
girls,
soap,
tampons in vodka and stuff from their pussy or they go to the club,
but they have fresh,
minty breath.
There's breath is perfect.
Go back to this,
go back to this age thing.
I had some people one night and I was drunk.
I was in Atlanta by some people from the CDC at my show.
And they were saying exactly what you're saying to me.
Yeah.
Because said something about,
I don't know,
I forget the Gee,
I may,
I'm sure I made a joke.
And they came out and they like set me straight.
They're like,
listen,
it's very,
oh my first,
the,
this is nominal.
It's not worth telling.
But one of the,
I got an aids test at 95.
And uh,
one of the first jokes I ever wrote ever before I was a comedian.
And I remember waiting the results and saying,
think positive.
No,
no,
think negative,
negative,
nothing positive or negative like I was.
And I was like,
am I was waiting in the waiting room.
And I thought,
that's funny.
Like you want a positive result,
but you would have negative,
positive result.
And I was joking with my head,
I said that.
Then they came out and they said,
no,
you exactly what you just said.
Yeah.
It's very hard to get apparently,
and this is just,
this seems to be a consensus.
I wouldn't say something like this to try to encourage people to not use
condoms,
but it just seems like through now gay sacks and the other hand,
if you were having gay,
anal sex,
the same thing you're dealing with like open tissue.
It's not skin.
It's not the same.
You know,
it's not the same as the skin on the out.
If you come on someone's back,
I'm pretty sure they're not going to get aids,
but if you come in there butthole
and you've got the hip,
weird things can happen.
It's getting,
it's getting bad.
I think there's a lot of scary diseases out there,
man.
I think,
uh,
we were super lucky that we live in live in this amazing time as far as like
modern medicine and what they could figure out.
Not figure out,
but it's always going to be weirdest when diseases come through sex because like
Ebola is scary as fuck and malaria is the scariest of all time.
Malaria has killed ready for this.
There's a fact malaria has killed half of the people that have ever died,
ever.
What?
Yup.
Half the people that have ever died on the planet earth ever were killed by
malaria
at of all the reasons why people died.
Car Accidents,
plane crashes,
AIDS,
cancer,
malaria,
killed half of the people that have ever died ever.
Uh,
how's that possible?
Well,
because malaria is a mother fucker.
Malaria kills millions of people that we just don't hear about it.
Cause we don't get malaria in California.
We don't get malaria in America.
But if you're in Africa,
you are fucking terrified of malaria.
Hold on.
Okay.
This is not a fact.
That I'm sure is right.
But black people with sickle cell anemia develop the sickle cell gene to defend
against malaria.
Correct.
Whoa,
I've never heard that before.
Uh,
Jamie,
because someone helped me find some type in sickle cell malaria.
Wow.
That's interesting of true.
It's something to do with the sickle cell gene is what is what protects black
people in Africa for malaria.
Because the body tried to define it.
I only know this because when we were traveling to Africa,
we had to take malaria pills and they fucked me up.
They really fucked.
I heard they Cribble you.
Oh my dreams were like insane.
I've heard people saying that they would rather get malaria then deal with the
malaria medication cause they get malaria.
Then they'd just get antibiotics and get it taken
care of.
Mystery solved how sickle cell hemoglobin protects against malaria.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well I learned that in Africa from a black dude.
He goes,
when I go,
how come you're not taking him learn medicine?
They said,
I'm black.
A new article is likely to help solve one of the longstanding mysteries of
biomedicine in a study that challenges currently held views.
Researchers unraveled the molecular mechanism whereby sickle cell hemoglobin
confers.
That's what says,
confers a survival advantage against malaria.
Wow.
That's racist.
I have a buddy that died from sickle cell,
uh,
guys to train with back Boston.
My friend Walter.
Really?
Yeah.
He was like really talented,
a taekwondo fighter and he would uh,
come in and train like really hard for a short period of time and then he would
get sick and uh,
he was always one of those guys that everybody was like,
where's Walter?
Like,
where's,
he was like super talented,
really good,
but he would get sick and he just couldn't compete and then he would get better
and he would just look like a world beater.
He was like really fucking good,
really talented,
really smart.
Just knew,
knew how to fight and then just kept getting sickle cell.
Just kept getting worse and getting better.
And this is like
early eighties,
or that's when it was taken out.
Brothers left and right.
Maybe even earlier than that.
It might have been 82.
Who Do we sell them and Leroy's Selman played for the bucks,
do we sell them?
Was a defensive back and Dewey Seldman had sickle cell anemia.
That was first time I ever heard of it.
But I remember telling my dad,
I think I have sickle cell anemia because I'd heard this too.
My Dad was like he black.
I don't think so.
That's amazing that it came from malaria.
Yeah,
well it makes it makes sense.
I mean you,
your body or the human body is going to try to figure out some way to get over
this hump.
This is the most deadly disease I think ever.
If I had a gas,
I would say malaria is probably the most deadly disease ever.
But everybody's scared of it.
Right.
I'll tell you what,
rabies is pretty fucking bad cause I got,
I got bit by a bat and Costa Rica very bad.
And I thought,
I thought,
I thought I had,
I,
I was like I got bit by a bat and you get the rabies shot.
And they were all,
you know Costa Cause I pulled Avida man a pure life.
Don't worry now you fine.
We don't have rabies down here.
Thought he'd be fine.
And then I go back and I come back to,
you know,
get my shots to go again.
And they said you want a rabies shot?
I said,
I've been bit by about once and the lady freaked and like laid it on me.
She was like,
she goes,
you know,
there's no recovery from rabies.
Like if you do in fact have rabies,
you'll die from rabies.
No.
And that's not true.
100% no,
no,
nope.
Not One person has ever knocked,
gotten bit by rabies,
gotten the shots in two days.
You got to him and within two days and ever lived ever fucking lip.
Now,
so everybody who gets rabies,
even if you get the shots inside of two days,
you still die.
If you get the shit,
you have to get the shots within two days and then you live and then you live.
Yes.
But if you don't get those shots,
oh,
I see what you're saying.
So if you don't get the shots,
you're dead a hundred percent
five months later you're sitting in a bed,
you start feeling sick.
When he's a scary man,
it starts with a sore back.
How many fucking times I lay in a hotel bed going,
God damn it.
Or rabies kicking in these fucking scared me.
You hypochondriacs Camacho.
I'm worse than you have.
No,
you never heard about when I thought I got genital warts,
what happened?
Oh,
did you like get a macro thing?
Magnifying glass and no,
look at the little individual cells.
No.
Oh,
it looks weird.
No,
but I did sit with my balls and Dick's and a bowl of vinegar watching quantum
leap drink a 40 vinegar because vinegar,
I don't know man.
I got fucked.
Get obsessive,
right?
No vinegar will tell you if you have genital warts,
so that's hilarious.
Let's tell you it.
The march we just slept,
you know,
it'll whisper to you.
You look down,
it's an exclamation point.
Never had one of those times where you looked at your dick a bunch like you like
have sex one night and then the next day you like kind of giving you a dick a
once over and you're like,
wait,
what the fuck is that?
It's kind of amazing how rarely guys do give their dick a once over.
Like how often do you like what we're dealing with here?
Every time
I go through the left,
look to the right side down.
So He's there and I'm like,
I got him pinned in Jujitsu.
Stare at your sac underneath in the mirror.
Paul Becker.
Was it just from fucking,
was it just like a sore from fucking too hard?
Well,
it started out as nothing.
You got to start off with a one night stand and I was working at Barnes and
noble and I went into the bathroom and I was looking at my dick nonstop and then
I start looking at those web journals,
those Ma not web during med med journals and then s and then I,
and then I was like,
Oh,
you know what?
Like like,
and this is,
I don't know if anyone has obsessive compulsive a hypochondria.
This is how it works.
You're like,
you know what?
I'm going to be fine.
I'm going to go get some stuff at cvs,
put it on my balls,
I will notice anything in the morning.
And next thing you know,
you're rubbing lotions and ton acton and fucking putting shit all of your balls
and Dick's thinking you're going to fix something and then it looks worse the
next day.
And then you're like,
all right,
listen to if all I gotta do is I got to,
I'm going to,
I'm going to do the tonight,
I'm stay with an act and then I'm going to get my bowls and Dick and a bowl of
vinegar tonight and that'll tell me.
And the next thing you know your Dick and balls would just give me getting a
fucking beating for like two days and then I'll look normal anymore.
And now you can't stop fucking with them.
You are literally like fucking magic dad.
Nonstop.
I'm not the only one that's been through this.
I know there are people who have done this.
A lot of guys out there pickle in their balls and deck pickle in there and you
just,
and then,
and then you're an affiliate and you can't stop looking at your desk.
You just like nonstop.
And why does it have to be filling?
Cause that's where I went.
I went to Philly here,
would affiliate with my cousin.
Hey,
but I stayed in this place and I was fucking listen to my name,
come take a look at my cock and vinegar.
And I literally go pickle.
Every conversation you start starts with like,
you know,
uh,
genital warts is very cold.
And then,
uh,
and then it went,
it took,
I mean,
I'll be very honest.
Uh,
uh,
I went to a dermatologist in Tampa.
I like spiraled out my mom like said,
come home,
you're fucking,
something's going wrong with you.
I flew home and I like,
you had to fly home to deal with this and it wasn't even general warts was it?
Even by the way,
in your Dick and vinegar,
you got to get on a plane.
All Jesus Christ use hydrogen peroxide.
It's way better than,
than vinegar.
Yeah.
You know,
why are you using vinegar?
You're just kind of starting,
by the way.
Did we didn't have the Internet back then.
We have the Internet back then marinate your Dick.
Just don't,
just don't,
don't try any home remedies.
Did you even bother googling it?
Oh,
Google wasn't around.
that's right.
This was like,
this is right when I moved to New York by 1997.
So yeah,
you'd have to get an encyclopedia and you know how hard those were standup to
thumb through the fucking do.
Does anyone remember the Dewey decimal system?
Like that fucking was so complicated to me.
Like I never learned it and I never had to.
Do you like do they even cover that kind of stuff?
Like if you got an encyclopedia or a medical encyclopedia,
would they talk about Dick Wards and home remedies like pickling your Dick and
vinegar,
where would you get that data?
Figlin Dick and vinegar.
I probably did get from the Internet.
The Internet was around.
It just wasn't like what it is today.
There was those books as homeroom Mindy books like medical books though my mom
used to have like,
like a kind of a book that like if you have a fever and you don't have Tylenol
tried to this,
you know words to that though.
It was like sure they had something they had to in rewards back then.
I wonder if they talked about it though,
because there's a certain innocence to that time where they just lay like to
sweep stuff under the rug and not talk about it for the longest time.
I wonder,
you know,
I wonder how much of that was discussed.
It probably called something different back then too.
Like Indian mounds or something.
What?
Uh,
I don't know if that's right,
but I'll tell you what,
there wasn't a lot of information back then and it was just what you'd get was
like literally what you'd get on the Internet now if your battery was dying.
Like that's the kind of internet information you get.
That's why aids was so scary because nobody made you.
Yeah,
I mean you,
you would have to like wait til a news report came out.
Yeah.
To find out like how you could get it,
how you couldn't get it.
And when's the vaccine coming?
2020 was how people found out about aids.
Yeah,
man,
stop and think about that.
Unless you read some Newsweek article,
like you had to read some,
some article and then it was up to the person writing the article.
Like they had a tremendous responsibility to get the facts right,
which they don't always do.
You know,
and then the facts change,
especially when it comes to science and medicine,
like the facts,
they change,
you know,
they find out new discoveries.
They have to back date things,
they have to change things you have to fit.
Oh well now there's a great,
uh,
believe it was radio lab.
There was a great,
yes it was radio lab on patient zero and it was all on the origins of aids,
how it happened.
And they think it happened from a hunter in Africa.
They think that it was a combination of two different diseases that different
monkeys,
God,
and they probably got it from eating each other.
And that a hunter who killed a monkey and was cutting the meat up must have cut
his hand and gotten that monkey blood in his,
in his body.
So the virus got into him and that was the origins of HIV.
He was gay.
Fucking fascinating.
I had nothing to do with get well,
I mean if he was okay,
well but that might have had sex with a woman or it might.
It's just by virtue of the way men have sex,
gay men have sex.
It made it easier for them to spread it.
That's available.
Yeah,
more susceptible.
And then on top of it,
there's the gay community loves to party,
you know,
and that's like a big thing that that Peter Duesberg guy that we had on that was
super controversial men.
I never had more people get mad at me.
Then you and Brian.
Carolyn,
yes.
And that guy,
I heard that who was a professor of biology at the University of California
Berkeley and he has this insanely controversial viewpoint on aids and 90 but
one,
I'm just say this before I repeat what he believes that 99% of the people that
are in his field disagree with him.
This is a very,
very small people,
small percentage of people that might just be him.
So this is,
but this is his,
his friends belief.
He believes that HIV is actually weak virus.
And he said that what it is a symptom of is a compromised immune system and that
your immune system is compromised from drugs.
And one of the things that he connected is the amount of people that die from
aids,
complications that were heavy drug users in the gay community.
And it's overwhelming crazy numbers,
crazy numbers because they're do ll night trade and poppers,
which are poppers and math and they just love to party because they don't have
kids and they but fucking woo seventh grade old time having a good time man.
Um,
so it was his contention that HIV was just a symptom that their immune system
was already fucked up and that if,
if we looked at it correctly instead of from a social point of view,
everybody's looking at it as like a social stigma.
It's something that can't be questioned because it's such a blight on the gay
community and we should all rally and help them and you,
you can't question what,
what's actually going on.
They obviously have a disease that's killing them off and we need research and
funding and all this.
And he was saying when you get outside of that cloud of emotion that's attached
to this and,
and politically correct thinking.
And one common denominator you see with these people with a lot of them is heavy
drug use.
So what he believed is that your immune system gets shattered from doing all the
drugs and then when they test you HIV shows up,
but they raised the HIV is there,
it's like if you are healthy,
your body would battle the HIV.
Now HIV researchers think he's out of his fucking mind,
but they are saying that there is ways to make it so the you HIV doesn't show up
the people's body.
Exactly,
yes.
That's,
that's more recently,
that's within the last,
I believe the last decade or so.
I think those things are called protease inhibitors.
And I think that's one of the ways that they,
uh,
have figured out how to,
I think they have even better stuff now.
Um,
I don't know what the latest in HIV medication is,
but if they have something that could uh,
make it get to that point,
you would kind of assume that that would like,
I know,
I know a few people actually that have it,
that have HIV and they take the drugs and they are,
um,
one of our friends works at the comedy store and they are uh,
unperceptive and in December you don't,
what's the word?
Presumable perceivable.
Thank you.
You can't,
you can't test it when,
when you test them they show up negative but he knows that he has it somehow or
another,
it's like dormant in the system and if his immune system drops down and it gets
all fucked up but could be parties too hard or something like that and he
doesn't take his medication,
maybe it would come back and see that doesn't necessarily mean that Duesberg is
right.
It's,
it's,
it seems very complicated.
It seems like the doing the drugs doesn't help.
That's what it seems like to me to say that the doing the drugs is the reason
that these people should get aids.
And it's not the HIV and the drugs,
it was compromising their immune system.
That's not necessarily true because there's not a lot of people that are just
getting HIV and then getting better on their own with no drugs,
with no medication.
So it could be that one thing we all know is it doing a lot of drugs is bad for
your body.
So when they're doing crystal meth and Emile nitrate and they getting crazy and
not getting any sleep,
that's terrible for your body and any disease that you have when your body's
already wrecked is going to have a better grip on you.
This just the fact,
yeah,
when we all know that that's the,
that's what the common cold with the flu,
with anything,
you have the flu and you get fucking hammered and start doing meth.
You're gonna feel like shit,
you know,
because your body's already wrecked.
Your immune system's already torched.
So I don't necessarily think that his conclusions make a lot of sense to me.
A nonscientific nonmedical person,
I think.
I think he probably one of the reasons why all these people are angry at him
cause he's jumped to some unscientific conclusions or some conclusions at least
that they don't think are scientific or,
or just politically incorrect,
but definitely politically incorrect and that's what a lot of us are
researchers,
man,
they've spent decades.
You know,
the cynical point of view is that like people that are conspiracy theorists
would say,
you know,
hey,
the money is in the treatment and the cure man.
You know,
what they want to do is I'm going to continue making money.
You'd have to be extremely cynical to think that that's the case.
Like they say that about cancer,
but they kind of know how to stop cancer in a lot of ways.
They could prevent a significant amount of cancer if people just cleaned up
their diet,
cleaned up their diet,
started eating healthy and exercising,
that would,
that would stop a lot of it.
A lot of it.
What percentage,
I don't know.
But if you cut sugar out of your diet and you started eating healthy and you
started exercising on a daily basis,
how many people would be way healthier than they are now?
Probably a lot.
And now there's definitely people that get cancer because of genetics.
There's that.
It's not all of it is due to poor diet and stress,
but that can help when your immune system's going bonkers and you,
you're fucking tired and stressed out all the time.
That shit ain't good.
But it does,
you know.
So that's all it's everyone's looking for a one or the other.
They are looking to point the finger at like one source and I think it's a
combination of a bunch of different things that makes your rack
see.
I always thought the CIA created aids.
Did you hear that presidential thing that came out this week?
Ronald Reagan and Gorbachev?
No.
Like them talking about HIV and aids are in the know or late.
They pretty much,
they were just making fun of it and like people were like,
where's the prison going to mouth a mouth kiss?
And,
and they weren't taking it serious at all.
And like the,
the press was like,
are you guys not taking aid serious or HIV series?
And they just continued to joke about it,
like Reagan's administration and stuff like that.
Audio about it.
Do you remember that woman who was a publicist who made that joke on Twitter
line?
That's a book I read is uh,
so you've been publicly shamed?
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
John Ronson Justine's Soco was,
I mean it fucking destroyed her life.
Now I'm not even,
I'll tell you what,
I'm this far out of it.
The stuff,
I read the book like where she works now and I've heard stories about her now I
won't even share cause I don't like public shaming.
I don't think it works.
And I don't think it's,
I don't think it's benefit to anyone.
I think it makes just makes the people that shame good.
Wait a cotton picking minute.
I don't like what you're saying.
I like it.
Oh,
I don't,
I don't like it either.
I think,
again,
it's what we were saying earlier,
it's this,
it's these people that are just looking to be outrage.
That's a big part of it.
And there's some things that you probably should shame people for.
Like Bill Cosby,
like if you want to go around and drugging and weight raping women,
yeah,
you should be shamed for that.
But you really,
you should be prosecuted if you're not prosecuted than definitely shamed.
But like,
but like,
but like get prosecuted me.
Let them go to fucking jail and I don't really care to shame him.
Just send him away.
He's definitely experiencing hell,
right.
Whether whether they lock him in a cage or not,
I don't give a fuck of that.
Guys living in the lap of luxury,
he's experiencing hell because he's gone from being a guy,
been loved his entire career.
He's like revered.
He's like,
well,
you look at him,
he's one of the great,
if you had a mount Rushmore of standup comedy,
you'd have to put bill Cosby's head on there.
You'd have to,
yeah.
But he's impervious to,
he's impervious to shame.
I bet.
I bet it's like a great white shark.
He was so fucking condescending to everyone he spoke to.
I heard the theory ever fucking met someone with like,
Hey man,
I'm bill.
Nice to meet ya soul like just staring down like DC Ben.
He's got a story of that.
Just the way he treated him in DC was like,
what a fucking Dick.
What happened?
I don't know.
I'm fucking,
it was probably 12 years ago that I heard the story.
So for me to repeat it,
start making up stuff.
DC walks into his trailer and bill Cosby's raping this woman in DC.
He's like a,
I do a great impression of you and started doing it and go,
cause he was right when the woman,
the girl starts waking up,
she hears bill Cosby.
Bill like not cool man.
I don't use my voice with them.
That's,
I mean,
that's what DC told me.
Did he have like a luchador mask on it?
That's what I heard.
Yeah.
I think when I'm Mexican wrestling masks,
that's what I heard.
I think so old school bill Cosby.
Yeah.
But what were you gonna say about Justine Sacco?
Oh,
well that's a perfect story.
When we talk about someone like cracking a joke about aids,
you know she mateze picked fairly recently.
She was talking about going to Africa.
She goes,
I think the exact quote was,
I'm going to Africa hope that I get don't get aids.
Lol.
Just kidding.
I'm white.
Yeah.
She says she's just,
and she tried to say,
I think that it was like that.
She was pointing out the disparity of how white people did it.
She just did a poor job at please bitch cracking a joke.
Cause she,
she was in that first generation of funny girl.
No,
I'm to,
I'm going to say girls only because they ran the internet at this time.
They were Twitter.
Was she black too?
No,
no.
But there was a bunch of girls that women that overtook and showed people how
funny women were on the Internet through Jenny Johnson high five.
Jenny Molan,
Jay Johnson,
high fives.
Very funny.
Fucking really.
She says some really funny shit.
Slash.
Lien.
Our friends slash thing from Toronto,
Oxford.
They're all funny and it's women.
And she was in that first generation of those women who would post outrageous
shit.
Jenny Kenny Kelly Oxford's posted what time?
And I fucking lost it.
I lost it laughing and she deleted it cause she was afraid of it,
I think was that a women who like meant women who wear pads love to smell their
menstruation.
Whoa.
And I loved that.
I just thought it was my wife's like,
my wife would never wear a pad like in her life.
I remember someone offered a packs.
He had a period.
It's like,
what pad?
I'd rather put a sock in my fucking pants.
What are you fucking kidding me?
Hadn't people hate Tampon people?
Yeah.
Looks like a war going on.
You see in Mac,
the first PC and Mac first generation.
But that fight.
But uh,
but I think Justine sacco was in that group of women.
She was,
I didn't know that.
I didn't know she was always Ligo.
Not,
not like friends with them,
but it was funny,
that generation of,
she had had a bunch of outrageous tweets.
I in the book,
I read that from John Ronson that she was just outrageous and funny and would
say the inappropriate things.
And then all of a sudden got,
there's another,
there's a young lady who worked with mentally disabled adults who took a picture
at Arlington cemetery where it said,
uh,
please be quiet and be respectful.
And she did this like fake yelling and flipping off thing.
The girl's life got destroyed,
destroyed.
And apparently her thing was posting funny pictures of her doing the opposite of
whatever the sign said.
Science had no smoking in her with a cigarette and a lighter.
Yeah.
And like,
and like an over the top.
Yeah.
Girl picture.
She got destroyed to the point where she didn't,
she's like,
I don't want to get my name cleanse because I'm afraid I'll come back up in the
thing because they can now clean your name.
Here's the real one.
There's one that fucked up.
Clean your name.
There's,
what does that mean companies
that they go through the cleaner and it sounds like the professionals at French
guy.
What's that guy?
Uh,
no,
the,
the professional side though.
The,
yeah,
they go through,
they do it a lot.
I think they think they do it for sex offenders.
Whoa.
And uh,
by my reading comprehension skills aren't tops,
but like for people that don't want their name on the Internet for whatever the
fuck they did,
guys that have been convicted of rape.
Right.
And so what they do is they basically you pay them and then they flood the
Internet with websites that your name comes up on and fake pop up that you go to
the website and it says temporarily unavailable or whatever.
And they just flood the Internet with that.
So that when you do find Justine soccer,
what's number seven on the list and number one is a semifinal final semi final
medalist for the,
this uh,
ran a five k.
So they just add shit to the internet to flood the water.
So it makes it more difficult to find information about you.
That would be the smart thing to deal with if somebody was fucking with you,
hire someone to write complete fiction about you all the time,
like all day long.
Like,
just make up shit,
get to the point where it's like finally thinly veiled,
like it's very difficult to tell like what's true,
what's not like almost like an onion story and just hire someone to do that all
day.
So like if Justine sacco had like a pile of cash,
if she was a scrooge McDuck and she just sat back with all our cash and said,
you know what,
I'm just going to hire a team of creative writers and it just going to tell my
story.
What's that like to just tell her story,
make up stories all day long about things that she did like constantly and make
them,
some of them seem reasonable and some of them seem completely ridiculous.
I hate to say this.
You're that guy.
What do you mean no cause you,
I remember you,
I'm sure you remember.
I hate to say this.
No,
but like,
no,
but like what you're saying is with in this fan base that you have,
there are people that,
you know,
hear stories and half truths.
Do you remember the time when everyone thought you really killed a mountain in
with a belt?
Nobody thought that it'd be so retarded to think that then I guess I didn't
think it either.
Did you think it,
oh dude,
there were a lot of people that are like,
hey man,
like tweeted me did Rogan really?
And there are people going,
no,
he didn't get tricked to tell you that.
Who told who said it?
Who said it?
And do some,
it was a parody website.
It was like an onion type website.
Oh it was.
But it got out there and like,
I don't,
I didn't read the website but hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
I didn't read the website,
but you gotta be hammered when you heard that story.
Oh,
there you go.
Well it just sounds fake knowing Joe.
It's like a mountain with a value.
How they,
how the fuck would you get a belt around a mountain lions neck fucking almost
texted you.
My own sister asks me if it's true.
No signs that you know,
this kid that I know that gets bullied.
And I told him the same thing about like you should go online,
take the boy's and like really just throw all this fake stuff on there,
make fake websites about them and ruin the Guy Online.
That's like nowadays the best way to get back at a bully like anonymous,
we can,
but I mean at the end of the day,
the bullies still the same guy.
You're not really hurting them.
You know,
you're not changing anything by making up a bunch of shit until the whole
heights or the middle school sees these websites and he's getting bullied for
being,
you know,
I have pictures of him and Leonardo Dicaprio Kissing.
He should be laughing at that unless he's an idiot.
Do you think it looks real son?
Thank you.
Um,
what does that,
uh,
what does that a soda water?
Yeah,
it's clean.
Do you want something else?
Sprite or something or soda?
What's the best?
I don't usually drink.
Vodka has flavor something.
Okay.
We'll give you some flavor.
Brian and prediabetic.
Yes.
No,
not Brian's prediabetic.
Ooh.
Do you watch it?
He said No.
Brian said no.
Do you watch a parascope when he went on a website and he definitely,
he's not.
He's telling me his eyes weren't working correctly and I'm like,
do you know that's a symptom of diabetes?
I definitely don't have it.
Like,
okay,
who you drank all the time.
You don't want your food.
I was that good.
Coconut water.
Oh really?
Did you get tested for diabetes?
Brian?
Are you just hoping to get tested?
I got fully tested.
The only thing I had was a little bit of a lack of vitamin D,
which is I guess normal or being assigned.
It's called being outside.
That's the only thing you had.
Yeah.
You want one.
Vitamin D is a a pretty normal ailment or pretty normal?
I think there's jaundice.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Well George and I both with jaundice and you'd have to sit and hold them by the,
by the sun,
like by the window and let the sun hit him and then you'd watch him turn from
yellow to white.
I don't know if that's true.
I just remember hearing that they turned from yellow to white.
How bizarre is it that your body produces a vitamin from the sun,
like the sun hits you and it actually produces vitamin D and I had a convertible
and I live in Los Angeles and I still was that.
And it's like really need to be actually out there,
you know,
we're very rarely like out in the sun.
Right.
What was the last time you were sunburned without going to a tanning bed?
That shit's not good either.
Tanning beds.
I have a friend who just got a,
my friend Cameron Hanes,
he just got a big chunk of his face cut off.
Wow.
Skin cancer.
It's hard.
I don't it start,
was it like a weird mole on his face?
I'm a Molly guy and it's scary because like a half,
a lot of my moles look like they are,
they should be cancer.
But then you get them checked and like know if it turns red and starts to like
hurt spread and stuff.
Wait,
wait til,
I'm sorry.
Tell me about camera.
I'm more interested in cameras.
Weird the on his face.
And,
uh,
I went to the doctor and they,
they check it and I'm like,
Yep,
you gotta cut it out.
They make an appointment late.
They sliced them like a box cutter.
Like he was in a war with the gang banger,
cut his face open and stitched it back up.
They took a big chunk out of his face,
but his camera and use sunscreen when he goes hunting.
Um,
no,
I don't think so.
It probably doesn't.
Money runs either.
He runs a lot.
He's a police,
right?
Yeah,
he's,
he's doing,
he's getting ready now for,
uh,
a double ultra marathon.
It's something called the big foot race.
It's 200 plus miles,
I think it's 204 miles.
No.
Yup.
It's two days.
Two days.
These guys were,
why the sound guy?
That was James Deamer who does,
uh,
who does those ultra marathons?
Cam's done a bunch,
well,
not a bunch.
He's done a bunch of marathons,
but I think he's done three 100 mile runs and one of them,
he actually did a 24 hour race and he won 106 miles.
I think it was something like that.
Something crazy like that.
106 and a now he's going to essentially double that
or close to it.
That's fucking insane.
Yeah,
but you don't know what it was.
I'll say this guy's like Cameron and uh,
who's the guy who had the children travel general for,
can't remember his name right now,
but it's a good friend of yours is also Steven Nelson Mandela.
They've made hunting.
Uh,
cool.
Again.
Yeah.
Like I like the,
I listen to those stories and it's hunting's you know,
when I was a kid,
hunting was about like waking up early and going out with your dad and,
and fucking being tired and cold in the car and then going out and then possibly
someone would hit you with buck shot like at some point in the day.
But like now it's like,
it's,
it seems like these adventures,
which,
which almost as a man,
like my wife got chickens and,
and I understand she's never been more happy about a project in her life and she
met.
Got It from your wife.
When we went to your house,
she saw that she thought it was so fucking cool.
She had been talking about forever.
Finally gets the chickens every morning she let the chickens out,
she talks to them,
she's trained them.
So they'll come up and get on her and,
and I watched that.
And it's a primal instinct that's inherent in humans is to almost,
I want to,
I want to plow my own field.
I want to do my own work.
I don't have to feel like I did something and those guys want to,
and when I listen to you,
I'll do podcasts about it.
I get it makes me want to go hunting.
And I told you I'd never kill an animal.
I'm never,
I don't know if I'd be cool with it.
I don't know that I'd have killed a couple animals.
I take that back.
But I had a pig roast and house and kill,
killed animals are definitely killed animals but never like no with a shotgun
now with the gun.
Never the bone arrow.
But it makes it seem like,
hey man,
I might need this in my life.
That sounds so fucking stupid,
but I might need this in my life to get out into nature with me and a gun and,
and be afraid because you're in the jungle,
you're in the woods and a bear might roll up on you.
What you are out there to hunt might roll up on you and get,
it's like this fight club,
cut your fingernails cause you're fighting type thing.
And,
and I like I just started going back out to that place we shot shotguns and
shooting sporting clays cause I was like,
I was like,
man,
maybe this,
maybe this will,
maybe this will be like a new form of therapy or maybe this'll be like a new
thing that blossoms into me growing.
Does that make any sense?
It does make sense.
Like the shotgun that what you were,
the way you were explaining it.
I've never done that sporting clay stuff,
but it sounds really fun.
Yeah.
That what it is
is,
uh,
well you can explain it,
but you go out there and there's a course and all these things pop up and you
shoot him,
but you,
you're going through this course and as you're going through this course,
some of them are rolling on the ground.
Some of them they shoot up,
they launch them in the air and they're these clays,
just like those same sorts of things,
right?
Like those,
those 50th,
yeah,
it's 15 different stations that you go to.
You can go to 15 dissertations and they're all set up differently to be
different types of birds,
different types of animals.
So like some will be like a rabbit where the clay roles on the ground out in
front of,
but you don't the real,
the real sport in it.
And I gotta be honest with you,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
it's like fine tuning your machine where you get up there,
you have your gun,
your shotgun and a,
we did the two shot,
top and bottom right.
And you out there and you go pull and your buddy hits the button behind you.
And all of a sudden two things come out of the woods and you don't know where
the common from and you don't know where and you just feel like fuck just and
you try to get it and then there is this thing that hits on your head and hits
in your fucking cerebellum.
We,
you're like,
I couldn't feed my family today.
Like you get done.
You're like,
I couldn't find my family that day.
I'm trying to defend myself or my family.
I'd be back in the woods tomorrow.
And,
and it was,
it's cool man.
I,
I wish I could remember the name of the place to say it so people would go
there,
but it was fucking packed.
But the day we went,
someone setting,
I posted a video on my youtube page cause we were walking doing the walk and a
deer just walked across us and we've fucking shotguns and it tears just walked
across.
I go,
we can fucking kill it.
Like we have loaded shotguns,
but we're tuning sporting clays and we're like,
what the fuck?
You might not really even kill it.
You wouldn't even,
you just fuck up a tide.
You have heard of the evening.
We heard it pretty bad because you're,
you're,
you're shooting spray those little tiny pellets.
He would need a slug.
Like they use slugs to hunt deer.
Well that's the,
with a shotgun.
That's the one thing about that video is I posted and I was like hunters and uh,
anti gun people will both hate this video cause hunters were like,
you couldn't fucking kill it.
Right.
And Go,
people are like,
how are you,
why do you have guns?
So I'm like right in that window of stupid.
Well,
what's going on is when you're out there and those things are running by like
your focused folks forced to focus on them.
And when you forced to focus on the clay rolling on the ground or the one
launching through the air,
it takes you away from your pro,
your problems and your troubles.
It takes you away from thinking about all the other things that are going on in
the back of your brain constantly,
whether it's bills or stress or a schedule or did you try it on the road?
Yeah.
I mean,
you're constantly doing things and you,
you have all these obligations and all these people tugging at you all the time,
dude.
And it just happens the second you get kids,
you commit to all that shit.
It's like,
it's like growing up,
I,
I talked to my therapist about it and he was like,
it's like when did your stress start?
Like when did you start really caring,
giving a fuck?
I finally give a fuck when I had kids.
And then you go out hunting and you're like,
I don't know.
It takes you back to,
it takes me by society.
Fucks up what being a man is about so much and make you overthink it and not let
you be it.
And sometimes when you're a man,
it's fucking,
someone called me a bro Comic and I'm like,
Dad,
I'm just a fucking person.
I happen to have a perspective cause I have a dick.
And if that's my perspective,
call me Bro Comic.
That's fine.
But like,
but like,
uh,
I don't even know what the fuck I was sets.
It's a weird pejorative.
That robe pejorative.
It's so funny.
People love using it.
He said dismiss anything that anybody says.
Yeah.
If you're into manly type activities,
you have to be a bro.
Like he should be ashamed of your gender.
Bert.
Kreischer I fucking love MMA.
I get kicked out of bars when Conor McGregor wins.
Like
I got kicked out of a fucking be fucking buffalo wild wings got kicked out of
Buffalo Wings twice this year.
Why Buffalo Wild Wings,
Conor Mcgregor's when I got kicked out and I got kicked out in Utah because I
was standing up and drinking a beer.
Wow.
Hold on.
Let's go to the economy McGregor one first and then we'll visit the Utah one
because I need to know about this.
So you're watching the UFC,
they're playing it in the bar.
Yeah.
So when you're playing the UFC is like anytime you're there,
you've been the one line,
I'm going to jump ahead of you for two seconds.
There is next to our next to us is a man and his wife,
uh,
probably 25 with their,
two year old child watching this fight in uh,
Ohio.
So whatever time it happened where you were at,
its mind you,
it's Ohio.
So it's like probably like 10 yeah,
10 at night.
I'm going to say I'm gonna Probably say 11 by the time Macgregor got on on.
Okay.
You watched the main event,
right?
Yeah,
I'm watching all the fights,
but Conor McGregor,
two hour,
three hour difference.
Oh,
that's even later than that then.
Yeah.
Okay.
So there's a child on it with an IPAD,
right?
So it's probably like 12 it's probably like midnight and there's a child there.
So we're watching,
I bring my whole crew out,
we're on the road and I'm like,
this is the one thing that makes you sane on the road is like,
one thing that makes you really Kinda,
I made,
makes me touch into life is like you're on the road,
you're working.
And then my cameraman,
John Man's would always be like,
hey,
UFC is on tonight.
Come on.
We gotta go watch Rogan.
And like,
so my whole crew,
we'll go out,
we'll go to buffalo wild wings.
They always show it and we'll all watch it.
And when you comment like one of the fun things like you know people that don't
know,
they're like,
you know that guy?
And I'm like,
yeah,
it's,
but it's a connection to life where you're like,
I'm lost on the road.
And then you hear a friend on TV and you're like,
I'm back in and this is the shit I like and more men and we're watching UFC.
Conor McGregor is fucking losing that fight.
It looks like he's losing that fight.
And the last minute he comes in and I've been cheering from the whole fucking
time and everyone Ohio hates his mother fucker and I am cheering from the whole
time cause he's a precious Irish saint.
And the second he knocks him out or fucking takes him down or whatever,
we ended it.
Shirt comes off and I'm like,
that's what's up.
That's what's up.
And that's against the licensed they have for serving food,
having no shirt on,
take your clothes off in a fine dining establishment was guilty.
Describe Conor Mcgregor and an angel or something precious Irish,
saint.
Precious.
We don't get many of those yet.
Ricky Patton,
you get Conor McGregor hat and whatever his name was.
Joseph Dick Van Patten.
Dig back back.
Parents Steam.
We fucking love those guys,
man.
They're there are fucking the guys we have to go see.
Told you were not that bad.
That's funny.
That's hilarious.
But the shirt coming off get you kicked out so they grab you and the guy grabs
me and he goes,
hey,
you can't take your shirt off in a buffalo wild wings.
And I go,
I'll put it back on.
And he goes,
and then he goes,
there's a child here.
I go,
hold on.
Don't use that defense.
We're watching a fucking blood sport on TV.
The child's been watching tonight to shirtless guys.
Don't fucking light me up for being the fucking start with them.
Kicked out with the kid out.
Dang.
Kick me out.
So I got kicked out of that one.
What if the kid's gangster and likes fighting?
He wouldn't even watch these on an iPad the whole time.
Maybe one day we'll do like,
we'll take it in peripherally.
Yeah,
like roar of the crowd.
I want to inspire them,
father.
So should me to fight the most ridiculous ones.
Buffalo wild wings.
I'm standing up having a beer guy comes up to me.
He's like,
man,
I can't have you doing that.
I need you to sit down.
I didn't realize,
I didn't realize you can't stand and have a beer in Utah that's illegal to stand
and drink a beer.
So when you go to a bar and you taught everyone seated,
you have to be seated and you have a,
you can't be walking around.
You can be like standing and standing at a bar.
So you can't like,
you know,
people go to a bar and they mingle and they walk around with their beer.
You sit down,
if you,
if you want to stand up,
you got to have no,
no beer in hand.
Crazy.
They used to be a rule that we thought for the longest time at the Tempe Improv
that you weren't allowed to drink on stage,
but it turned out was bullshit.
Denmark,
may he rest in peace.
Uh,
Dan Mar,
he's dead,
uh,
was decided for whatever reason that he was going to put up a fake sign that
there's a fake state law that says you can't drink on stage.
And so we would,
we would just bring flasks.
When Brian and I were there,
we went to a,
like a drive Thru BU's place,
which is hilarious.
Bought a flask full of flask and a bottle of Jack and then we're drinking on
stage.
I was just adding,
I was explaining,
I was adding warm diet coke to my cold diet coke because I like to,
I like a medium temperature.
So I have a flask of warm diet coke to always keep with him.
By the way,
I'm already on top of that lie to whoever asks,
because I'm such a drinker in public like you are like,
cause I like,
and I was already going,
what's my line real quick cause my teeth get too cold.
I don't want my teeth to get cold.
I just had oral surgery.
That's a good way to look at it.
So in Utah,
is that True Brian?
You can't,
doesn't say anything about that.
But it does say a lot of weird things about Utah.
Any beer over 4% eight BV is considered liquor.
Alcohol by volume.
Yeah.
And when they have Zions curtain there Zions curtain is,
is the,
they have it.
They won't pour your drink in front of you.
And so yeah,
they weren't see the bartender there were just mixing or pouring drinks.
They used to have it.
So you would buy like your drink in one spot and your mixer and another spot.
Like if you wanted a jack and coke they would,
they would,
you have the poor,
the Jack Daniels and the glass in one spot and then you have to go over and get
the coke and another spot.
Wow.
Oh I got another part of the bar.
This also says that you could only have 1.5 ounces of alcohol and your drink no
exception.
So like a long island ice tea would be like the worst drink ever.
And the ones that actually you can actually all sugar.
Hold on,
you can actually get along us honesty.
That's the exception in Utah because I had ordered a double Tito's and soda and
they said,
we can't do doubles.
We can bring you to drinks or we'll know that we can bring you a drink and a
shot,
but we can't do two drinks.
They can't order doubles.
Doubles.
Dude,
you,
you should've seen the look on my face as we're watching UFC in a buffalo wild
wings.
And the bartender says to me,
uh,
the manager comes up,
I wish I knew where we were in Utah because it's a smaller,
it's an,
it's not one,
it's not Provo or it's one of the smaller towns.
So it's not like the big city,
which I'm sure you're allowed to stand up and with your beer in your hand at
times.
But like,
but like he came up to me,
I had gone to the bathroom with my beer in my hand.
Who leaves a beer on the fucking bar and walks to the bathroom.
You'd have to be crazy.
Yeah,
I bring,
I walked,
I didn't even think anything of it.
It sounds ridiculous now just walk to the bar with my beer in my hand.
Take a piss and come back.
And he was,
hey man,
uh,
I can't have you walking around with that.
And I was like,
um,
excuse me.
He was like,
yeah,
I don't want you to walk around with that beer.
That's,
do you need to sit down?
And I was like,
sure,
sure.
And then I was like,
this is a white guy voice or a black guy was like,
I should have said he was white.
All my stories,
there was this white guy comes up,
he was going to be what?
Because he fucking was.
And so I,
I'm sitting there drinking my beer,
but I'm watching watching UFC.
So I'm standing up,
right,
like going through the moves.
It's kidding.
I'm kidding.
I did what?
I was standing up.
I'm standing up and I,
I'm drinking my beer and the guy comes up to me again in lights me up and I go
and now I'm confused.
But I'm also drunk.
So like I take a berry,
like guilty drunk perspective ever.
Anyone on a plane ever says anything to me about anything drinking.
I go,
Oh,
I'm sorry I'm done.
I'm done.
Like I'm never,
I'm not that company.
How many times does that happen?
How could Joseph like fucking 3 million miles and he hates flying.
Say gets drunk.
People complain a lot about you drinking on planes.
Yeah.
If you drink on planes at four beers,
someone will say something to you.
Yeah.
What did he say to you?
Eh,
had a lot.
Who says this?
The weight flight attendant.
So I've given you four.
This isn't a 30 minute flight and I'm giving you for it.
You know,
I w I,
you know,
I think we've had a lot.
Then you just go,
oh,
I automatically,
I'm like,
I'm so sorry.
I totally fine.
Don't worry about it.
And then I fucking white knuckle the rest of the flight because I can't because
I get nervous.
Fine.
I had a guy on the plane to South Africa telling me I've had a lot and I was
like,
I pulled him aside.
I was like,
I'm totally sober right now,
but we need to figure out a way where I can drink the rest of this flight
because I will have panic because I had 13 hours left and I was like,
so you come up with a system,
I'll agree with it.
And the guy looked at me very plainly is like,
I'll give you a beer every hour for the next 13 hours.
I was like,
perfect.
She's just crying.
And I was like,
13 beers on flight.
Uh,
we'll,
we're going to be honest.
Are we going to lie?
Let's be honest,
we nibble a little Xanax and went to sleep.
So I nibble a little Xanax and then had the next beer and then fucking,
I don't think you're supposed to mix those.
I know Joe.
That's why I was going to lie to Ya.
Fucking reason.
I lie sometimes there was a lady on a plane once,
I'll never forget her.
She was talking about how the grants have a Xanax and a glass of wine,
just a Xanax and glass of wine.
And she's looking at me like right at Xanax and I got,
I'm like dangerous.
No,
it's dangerous for how Geraldo,
what else is the Xanax?
Really?
Ah,
why would you ever listen to me?
But yeah.
Are you sure?
Oh Ho I'm a hundred percent sure.
In the same way Doug Stanhope is who I go to when I have problems.
Like,
like look when when he led your died,
both Stan hope and I both were on the like on the Internet going like,
hold on.
What was the,
how much ambient did he happened?
How much Xanax did he have?
Cause these,
these are real for people who take Xanax.
You need to know.
But from what I understand,
um,
Greg,
I hate,
I don't even know how to talk like this because I liked Greg a lot and I don't
want to tell Google what Greg draw the died off.
It was toxicology reports going to be a little bit of everything.
I'm certain because I think he was partying at the time when he definitely liked
pills.
He had an issue.
Uh,
I think I,
yeah.
Yeah.
I feel we were talking about Greg.
So I really genuine liked him and he was very sweet to me.
He's a great guy.
He was like fantastic.
Doesn't it take away from the fact that he had an issue with pills?
He definitely need.
He wasn't a great guy.
I know,
but I still have great people.
If issues of pills,
I say this then as a warning and using Greg's legacy is a warning.
It's not a bad thing to say it killed him.
I mean it's,
it's a good,
it's,
I think it's a good thing to bring up.
He,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
But I'll tell you what,
the whole reason I don't fuck with Xanax at all.
It's because of Greg,
because from what I understand,
he was coming,
from what I understand,
he was coming off partying.
He was in a hotel room,
he wanted to sleep.
He took Xanax and he,
and with Xanax sometimes,
uh,
when you use it,
and I,
I've used it a bunch in the past,
um,
you build up a tolerance and then you stop using it and you,
and it feels like shit when you stop using it.
Benzos are the worst.
They won't even admit you to Rehab if you're on Benzos.
Really?
Yeah.
I have a buddy.
You couldn't go to rehab because there's on Benzos and you stop using it.
And then the second you stop using it,
you get,
you get sick and you could die.
You could have a stroke.
But then when you go back to using it again,
you,
your tolerance goes back.
So you can take back to half a milligram and you feel it again.
But from what I understand,
Greg used more used to what he used to use and it just,
it has its way with them.
I could be totally wrong.
Uh,
and I,
and I hope I am.
I hope whatever.
I Love Greg.
I really,
genuinely,
I don't think there's anything wrong with what you're saying.
Yeah,
you can just,
you're saying something and everybody knew,
you know,
it's like Patrice dying of diabetes.
It's not a bad thing if you say the Patrice didn't take care of his health
because he didn't,
you know,
just the fact it doesn't make them any less of an awesome guy,
or an amazing comedian or just a fucking joy to be around.
He was all those things,
but he also had diabetes.
It didn't take care of it.
I think of him a lot,
and by the way,
these are all,
I,
whatever I say fucking shelve it until what Burt's memory of his narrative is.
But Patrice called his,
uh,
girlfriend Vaughn when he was having a stroke and he's like,
I feel weird.
Like something's going on.
I need to go to the hospital.
And you know,
it's so funny as a,
I think anyone with anxiety attacks and anxiety attack feels like that.
And so like sometimes I've been like sitting in a hotel room and I just feel
weird.
Like the,
like everything's shifting,
you're having anxiety at Pepin,
panic attack,
and then you start thinking of a stroke and I think of what Patrice said that
night.
I do over take yoga or do you ever meditate or anything like that?
No.
I'd like to get into meditation.
I really liked to.
Do you ever exercise when you're on the road?
No,
not,
not in the last 11 months.
No exercise at all.
Last 11 months probably.
No,
not at all.
I mean a little bit like scattered,
like I'll,
I'll,
I'll feel like up for other,
goddammit.
I feel like piece of shit.
Let me get down there and I'll run,
I'll run,
walk two miles and I'll lift some weights,
but not like,
oh,
like right now I'm on a pretty sincere regiment where I'm working out.
I think I'm about 10 I get a walk on my fitbit.
I walk like 10 to 12 miles a day,
which is pretty good burden.
About 4,000 calories taken in under 2000 day writing down everything I had
taken.
Other than this,
do you doing?
Yeah,
it's on my blog.
I just started doing it.
I started November 29th.
And who's giving you this number?
Like 2000 calorie me,
I'm registering the calories.
But why,
why did you decide on 2000?
Because weight watchers,
no,
just me.
His,
the decided that would be enough.
Now do you look at like what you're actually eating?
Have you ever tried like what kind of Diet you're on?
What I'm saying?
I can literally run through what I've eaten.
Okay.
Well just tell me like what kind of foods are you avoiding?
How about that?
Avoiding a lot of breads.
A lot of sugars.
A lot of brands are all bald breads,
all breads,
no sugar,
no sugar.
That's,
those are two great steps.
Yeah.
Uh,
all breads,
all sugars.
I'm cool with fruits.
I'm cool with a lot of vegetables.
Every vegetable can make its way in my mouth.
Vegetables or running a trainable,
nice lean protein.
Salmon,
chicken.
I do do the shredded beef every now and then,
which is just so good.
But it like if I do like we do Taco bowl night,
I do tortillas and Romaine lettuce.
Um,
and then,
and that's,
and like,
and then I'll do all almond butter and rice cakes as a snack.
The Avocado.
And you've been doing this for right now?
I'm six days,
six days,
and I've lost 13 pounds.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
If you can keep that up for like a few months.
Oh my God.
12 pounds,
12 pounds for Trump.
Boy,
four pounds.
That's amazing.
That's great.
Yeah.
And then I,
and I,
and I'm just really active.
I get up in the morning and uh,
and I just go at it.
It's like,
it's,
but it's,
it's very easy to do when you're at home.
It's really hard to do on the road.
Yeah.
It's not hard to do,
do it.
Let me take that back.
It's not hard to do when you do a stand up.
We do a stand up.
You have plenty of time,
man.
You got,
I always say to myself,
I work out at five o'clock everyday doing stand up.
Yeah,
you are.
Um,
you're in a weird position because you're doing a TV show and there's TV shows
and the trousers to be shown to actually three to two or three.
Which ones are you doing?
I'm doing everything on the network.
The ones,
uh,
I can't talk about two of them,
but okay.
Parts conqueror I can talk about because I've accidentally spilled the beans.
Um,
and then Trey,
you bring in Burke the conqueror back.
It's back.
We already shot a whole full season.
Jesus.
Yeah,
did,
uh,
six half hours.
Seven hours.
Wow.
It's good.
When you're out there doing this,
how often do you do in stand up?
Uh,
say I shoot birth,
conquer 13 weekends.
I probably did stand up during that time,
probably four weekends out of that.
But it,
no,
no.
I take that back probably more than that before while shooting.
Like I'll shoot,
I did Toledo while we're shooting.
I did,
uh,
Atlanta while we're shooting.
I did pitch.
I do like,
I'll do the weekend when I'm there or an abbreviated weekend,
like Friday,
Saturday.
What do you think you'd be happier doing and you think you'd be happier?
Just doing stand up all the time,
just killing it on the road.
Or would you be happier if you continue to do these,
you know,
giant workload schedule shows like [inaudible] 11 episodes here,
12 episodes,
there are six of this,
seven of that on the road for 11 months.
Would you be more happy if you were doing standup?
You think?
Um,
I,
it's,
it's really,
it's not hard to say because my heart is in stand up.
It's always been in standup.
The only thing I'm proud of in my life is the fact that I am a standup comedian.
Uh,
the fact that I can,
and it doesn't happen all that often,
but the fact that I can roll into the comedy cellar and I'll know Jim,
I know Bobby,
I'll know all the guys there.
The fact that it's like a fraternity that you've earned that you can't get,
you can't like just parent.
Your parents pay money and you join it.
Um,
I will say very candidly that money is having money is really nice when you have
a family.
Uh,
traveling stinks.
But like,
man,
I've gotten opportunities in my life this last six years that no one will ever
get in their life.
I mean like,
uh,
like from doing the show,
this doing the show is like,
it's amazing.
I mean,
it's working on travel channel's amazing.
Anthony Bordain would tell you that like at the same thing,
you just have these experiences done,
nine of the ones on TV,
but these great life experiences that,
I mean,
I,
I'm a,
I'm a horrible person to be sitting next to with my wife at a party because
someone will go,
oh,
I just did this and I haven't,
I have five experiences that are so much different,
cooler,
insane,
unbelievable than anyone's.
I'm,
I go to this all the time.
You called me one morning and you said,
what are you doing?
And I said,
I'm riding Vietnam,
I'm riding a moped in Vietnam through rice patties.
And you were like,
are you fucking writing about this?
And I was just sitting in a rice patty going like,
I was like,
ah.
I was like one of the coolest calls ever.
Yeah.
So like I don't want to lose that.
I and I,
I love that network and I love the people that work in that network.
I always want to do that.
But I think you know this and I know you know this and I know that bill,
no bill burr said the same thing to me in an Al Madrigal said the same thing to
me is that I've definitely unfocused on stand up for the last year.
Last year I've been,
I've been touching go.
I don't know,
I always,
I'm like that I got the same shit that those star athlete quarterbacks like
Michael Vick's brother had that he had just a bunch of talent and a bunch of
opportunity and then just was like fuck it,
I'll go pro and then didn't go pro.
You know I feel like that's sometimes where you're like I got a lot of talent
and I,
I got a lot of ability and I can go around and fuck around on stage and have a
good time.
But when it comes to like making a solid hour and like,
and like doom a buns.
Did I look at bonds cause he's my contemporary Tommy Tommy,
Tommy Scorer.
Yeah.
I look at him.
I look at Ari,
he's my contemporary,
these are my contemporaries.
And I go,
man,
they're murdering that.
They're,
they're killing it.
And now,
now granted,
and Ariana talk about this or it's like,
I'd love to have your job.
That's such a cool job.
But like,
where's,
where's the trade off?
You know,
like a little bit.
There's gotta be a trade off 100%.
There's no way around it,
man.
I got to retweet something for our,
I'm just remembering those,
um,
there's going to be a trade off 100%.
There's no way around it.
If you're going to do,
I mean,
that's how I always felt when I was doing,
um,
fear factor,
but always felt like a big trade off.
But go back to yourself in a time machine.
Yeah.
Well,
I would've done it.
I would do it again because I made enough money that I didn't have to give a
fuck about anything.
And in that,
not in the,
not giving a fuck,
having not giving a fuck money like true,
not giving a fuck money is when you can be yourself.
You don't have to say,
oh I shouldn't say this because then people are going to be upset at me.
Maybe that'll stop me from getting an audition or stop me from getting a,
but if you,
if you have enough money that you don't have to worry about that anymore,
then you can be yourself.
So on stage you can be yourself.
Uh,
I'm still,
I'm always like,
I'm not,
not going to be myself on stage,
but,
but here's the question,
is there,
there's the Joe Rogan and stop,
there's a time we should stop hauling it out
and then,
and go and do what you love the best.
That's,
you know,
or do less.
I'm like not maybe not three shows.
Yeah,
definitely.
definitely three is too many.
The,
okay,
here's the question.
Um,
would without,
where do you consider whoring it out?
Cause I don't consider it.
I didn't think I'd done really for me out.
I hoard it out for like six years doing fear factor.
I don't think that my standup got better when I stopped doing fear factor pretty
positively.
Absolutely.
So go to like shiny happy Jihad.
It was like one of my best things ever and I did it like right when I or right
when it ended
and then uh,
from shiny happy Jihad talking monkey's in space is probably my best one after
that.
And that was no,
no fear factor at all.
No TV at all.
Just doing the EOC and stand up.
And then I honestly think like now might be doing too many things with a podcast
and then doing the UFC and doing standup might be too many.
I think podcasts and standup is like the way to go.
I think those are just having less stuff and more,
the more the less you have to focus on,
the more you can focus on those things,
you know?
And then free time,
free free times.
It's giant.
Not,
not having to go buy anybody else's schedule.
Like,
if you want to go out to the salt and sea and go visit that fucking weird guys
hill that he's painted and all these religious symbols and signs and crosses,
you should be able to just do that.
But then Whoa,
stop on that thought because that's what I do for a living.
Right?
But you have to do it with a camera and you have to be with these people and
everything.
You're still in the kitchen makeup bird.
I'm gonna to put a microphone on you and you're doing it for 12 hours a day,
and then you're going out to eat and some strange hotel in Boise with your
fucking crew.
You know,
it's,
there's great things to that,
no doubt about it.
But I think that if you ultimately want to do your best stand up,
you probably should do less of it.
Right.
Well,
life was a big believer in putting what you want in the universe.
And so like,
right when she told me that,
I think it's,
that might be a Scientology thing,
but scientologist,
no,
but I gotta be honest with you,
I like a lot of their ideas.
I'm not a big,
I'm not,
I,
I like all there actually.
I like all their crazy ideas.
They're the ones that they really grounded in.
I don't get like one c runs.
I do believe in alien.
I do believe in aliens.
What do you believe what I'm saying?
I believe in aliens believe there's fucking life forms out there.
I don't know.
Things started us,
I don't know,
but I don't know if they started as just as much as,
I don't know if Jesus really got out and moved to fucking rock and was like,
I'm bad bitches.
So like,
like there's a lot like,
I like that I hear about Scientology.
That makes sense.
They've,
there's acting courses they teach in la.
Every young actor you ever hang out with took it at Scientology acting course.
And it's about accountability.
A fucking being a better person,
uh,
being your authentic self.
It's all Depok jokes
for shit while I'm in the middle of the reading going clear.
And when I say in the middle of it,
I put it down and I won't pick it up for a week or two.
And then I pick it up for a few days and I'll throw it down again.
I just can't,
it's so bizarre that I'm worried that I'm going to get infected by this dude's
ridiculous ideas.
[inaudible] was not,
my dad represented a Scientology through the infancy stages,
representing them as a lawyer,
one of their head lawyers.
Oh my God,
my dad.
Oh,
we're out of Tampa and continues to peel.
My Dad can grow.
Uh,
my dad is not like that at all.
My Dad don't even,
he's religious,
but Catholic,
only Catholic in his sixties,
like fearing the fucking,
you know,
whatever's going to happen.
Hell yeah.
Yeah.
And uh,
but my dad,
when we were kids,
l Ron Hubbard would show up.
My Dad's,
my dad would have to go out to his yard.
He lived in Clearwater and flew out to la a bunch because we are one the spot
over the rest of the Seahawks are.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
and so my dad doesn't believe in any of that shit.
My Dad's like a phony,
but like,
like phooey on that shit fool.
Yeah.
And my mom,
I remember they went to a party,
the one story is that my dad had told my mom,
don't fucking talk to anybody because you will get convinced that Shit's real.
But uh,
but yeah,
the uh,
the and has been through the Scientology acting classes and a lot of their shit
makes sense.
It's dated a girl who went to cytology acting class and really?
Yeah.
And I went to the acting class with her at the time.
And so,
uh,
I she,
cause she wanted me to go to her acting class.
She was burrowed it all are you on be at this time?
He did so much tension.
Yes,
I was.
Um,
she needed so much attention that was so ridiculous.
She wanted to watch,
she wanted you to watch her rehearse,
like for her thing in an acting class.
And she made me come to her acting class once when they did this thing called
private moments.
And this is what private moments are,
what a private moment is.
You would go onstage and you would just do stuff like they had like a little
set,
so they had like a bed and they had some books and they had like a little fake
kitchen area and you would just go on stage and pretend that you were just
hanging out by herself.
Like maybe reading a book.
And,
and I remember sitting there sucking this all for,
first of all,
the relationship was a joke.
It was a disaster from jump,
but she was hot.
It was fun.
But watching this whole thing go down,
I was like,
okay,
do you understand what's happening here?
They think this is,
this is not an acting,
you're not acting like this is an active,
what this is is that they're giving you a little fix.
Okay.
You have this desire for attention,
this overwhelming desire for attention.
And they say,
Hey,
you know what I mean?
How do you think for you to prepare?
But you can be the person on stage for the next 10 minutes.
Everyone's going to look at you.
Yeah.
That's killing me 15 minutes with people,
all my God thumb.
And that was okay.
Um,
what were you doing with the book there?
Is that how you normally would read a book?
Well,
what I read,
I like to eat things that are implied and so like that,
like it was like they would go over the public moment or the private moment
rather with,
uh,
the,
the various actors.
And I would love to sit there and listen to the things that they would say.
And they're PR I only made,
it's like two of them,
two classes where I was like,
I can't do this.
And all eyes.
That could be a TV show on comedy central if you just did that with comics,
five comics,
Jim Norton's tribe private moments.
And it's just five minutes of gym in a room just watching him fucking do gym.
You're see that show Nathan for you?
It's one of the,
I think one of my favorite shows.
That song.
It's a,
it's this comedian Nathan,
and he gets hired to like,
like go to these small businesses and help their business by using weird ways
like,
like as an example,
uh,
this bar ever since,
smoking became,
I got interrupted for right now.
It's totally sounds like comedy central's buying ad space through Brian.
He's
like,
does anyone see where you all companies?
So like as an example,
uh,
bars can't have smoking in them and they're saying that they've lost a lot of
money since that's happened.
A lot of smokers,
you know,
want to smoke in the bar,
blah,
blah.
So he found a loophole where you can make it a theater,
like a bar being a theater.
So he put up two seats,
sold like tickets so that you would sit down on these cds and just sit there and
watch a bar for an hour.
That giving the bar,
being able to smoke cigarettes as if there were a play.
And it's just interesting.
Like I,
we hacks normal everyday things.
It's really funny.
Uh,
but,
uh,
what's the one he did?
I mean,
he's a very funny Starbucks.
Starbucks,
Starbucks ones,
everyone knows where using parody laws,
he made a whole thing called dumb Starbucks.
Right.
It looked just like a Starbucks.
He could sell coffee because he was using a parody law and he does this like
every episode when it's so amazing.
Dumb Starbucks one dumb Starbucks.
It's actually a pretty good show.
Yeah.
Uh,
I,
I'll,
I'll be honest with the better show than Matt.
Who's the guy,
you guys,
I know his name.
It'll come to me.
The guy you had the,
he always wore the blue hat.
They'd had a comedy central show.
He came in.
I kind of felt like it might've been like a shoot of Freelander.
No,
no,
no.
I know Judah.
Um,
he did the show with coach Cook,
Ben,
that guys,
that guy show was super funny and he didn't get like enough of a of a chance.
What was the name?
Ben Franklin Franklin.
It was my first father Johnson been holding off.
Bang.
You got him in here,
right?
Yeah,
I liked his show a lot.
Do you ever hear his coach one?
No.
Oh,
it's so funny.
Can you play it Jamie?
But dog though.
Never mind central pause.
Oh really?
Uh,
cause they have their own sort.
They have the comedy central live.
They have their own website where they encourage people to go watch their show
and talk to Ari about that.
No,
he doesn't like it.
I don't know.
I haven't talked to me.
What does that mean?
Fucking no,
he doesn't like kids upstairs.
We're fine grownups.
And we know how this Internet works.
It's like,
look,
my kid's never going to get one over on me on me,
on Instagram because I've been in this shit and you're never going to bring a
person.
I promise you this.
And I,
I,
I bite my tongue sometimes a PSAP [inaudible] central.
I have a deal with them.
Okay.
He doesn't like it that they pull stuff off of youtube.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
I love you already.
This would already said I love you already.
Whatever you said,
Kj fucking we both agree with this.
Uh,
you never will.
Look fucking people find content is where you find content.
If content drives you to traditional media,
then so be it.
That's how this fucking business works.
We push it on youtube because that's where people are finding content.
And then you put it,
I put five minutes of a show on youtube and you like it and you go,
I kind of want to watch my show.
And then you go there.
Like when I look at at trailers,
I watched trailers for movies that I will see inside movie theaters on Youtube
and an on apple movies.
That's why I go,
okay.
And so comedy central and,
and,
and travels guilty of this as well.
Sometimes
they're trying to get the ad,
they try to get all the traffic to their web.
It's the older people in the company that don't technically get how people are
using their content and finding their content and,
and,
and enjoying their content.
I know how I enjoy mine.
I sit online and a fucking watch it on youtube and I go through youtube and I go
into a spiral and next thing you know,
I'm watching butterflies getting extracted out of a guy's back.
Now I'm looking at ear cleaning,
now I'm watching opion gym.
Like that's how it goes.
But no one that's like [inaudible],
my wife is 45 shouldn't use fucking youtube.
She's never used youtube in her life.
She tried to find a video the other day.
She's like,
it's on Facebook.
I go,
well,
Google the things you remember from it,
Google that and those are the codes keywords and you'll find it.
She's like,
no,
it's not on Google.
It's on Facebook,
but that's who's that?
She's running comedy central,
so when they go,
we don't want any of our content on youtube because it's a bunch of ad sales
dollars that we're missing out on.
Maybe they're accurate in some extent,
but I,
I would argue that
300,000 people watching me talk about fighting a bear on Ari's.
What's,
this is not happening now on youtube.
I would venture to say not one person woke up that morning after they saw that
and went to comedy central.com and then said,
hey,
check this out.
Swipe,
swipe,
swipe.
This is Bert.
They're not going to go there.
Did they understand that you can get money from Youtube ads?
They just need to control their own youtube channels and then they could have it
on youtube and it would be on the comedy central channel on Youtube and put all
their stuff up there and they would make plenty of money and I don't think it
would cost them shit because no one's paying for anything,
man.
No one's paying for anything and not going to pay for shows unless it's on apple
TV and you can just buy the whole season like game of Thrones or something like
that and watch it.
Or like a show like walking dead.
I pay for the walking dead so I don't have to watch those fucking commercials
because I've made the mistake of recording it on live TV and then trying to
watch it when I had been used to watching it on an apple TV.
It's unwatchable.
The fucking commercials are brutal.
Anytime something happens to fade to black and a fucking dancing tied box comes
on the screen and it's horrible.
It's awful.
Who's no commercial option is awesome by the way.
It's like an extra five.
Another thing,
Brian's being paid for comedy central sponsored by Hulu.
Some,
it's,
it's a new era and I think you're right that a lot of people need to understand
that having things on youtube,
it doesn't take money away from you.
It makes your show bigger.
You know,
the more Ari has his content on Youtube,
the more it's going to make that show bigger than more comedy.
Central's going to get more viewers,
the more ad dollars are going to make is not taking any money away from them.
It's making it bigger.
It's just gonna make a show bigger
period.
I mean,
think about,
think about we,
we've talked about this and touch on this at certain times,
but the fact that we have free content out there,
the fact that I fucking three,
four years ago told a story on your podcast that changed the scope of my career
and I never make any money off that.
I don't make any money off of the guys that have posted it.
I don't,
I don't give a fuck.
you'd think I look at become my minions.
Is the guy's name.
Do you think I looked at him and go,
go man,
he's making an ad dollars on this.
That guy was created enough to create a car,
a car,
uh,
a comic and add it to the story and it got me people to come to my shows.
That's all I give a fuck about.
Yeah,
it's free content,
man.
That's why I'm doing the vlogs.
Just think about like comedy central,
how much money they spend on advertising on billboards.
They had that giant billboard above sunset,
that billboard above sunset,
above pink dot.
Didn't get nearly as many people to listen or watched our show as a youtube
video would don't even close.
Here's what he's doing right now with the storytelling is so fucking smart.
It's so smart.
I've tried,
I've sold this to two people,
mom,
puppet by more than that.
But definitely to Orient Tommy.
I'm jealous in the most happy way for them.
Like I'm so happy that they did what they wanted to do.
But that's what's interesting to me is cause you're very successful right now.
But it seems like you look at what they're doing and it looks like more fun to
you than what you're doing,
or it looks like something more attractive to you than what you're doing.
Uh,
that's why you're saying you're jealous.
I am jealous.
I'm definitely jealous.
Not,
not,
but not,
I don't want people to associate that with not a bad thing.
No,
you're not.
You're not a petty guy.
It's like you said one time you saw Dave Chappelle ad at the comedy store
working out and you got,
you got,
I don't know if you said jealous,
but you said you got envious of his,
of like how great he was and you went home and wrote,
well,
I would say it's inspired would be the term that I would use.
You know,
I don't think it was a envious thing,
but it's certainly like,
wow,
God,
Tammy,
so good and you want to run home.
I don't like anybody can get envious.
We all can fall prey to that.
Maybe I'm broad stroke and then I don't let it in.
Man,
I know what it is.
I feel it.
I don't let it in.
I recognized turn it the other way.
I don't get it.
Like I don't like sit and go,
God,
I fucking want that.
That's jealousy.
That's envy.
But I recognize that feeling.
I recognize that feeling of like,
but we've all seen people that do get that jealous,
envy,
angry thing.
It's,
oh,
it's awful.
But I don't get that.
What I get for with Ari and like big jail.
Kristen Big Jefferson did.
Uh,
uh,
I went out to New York,
to do,
it's a crowd work show saw Crowdwork so he had,
and it was a bunch of comics.
It was at the village underground.
It was fucking him or no,
it wasn't,
whatever it was.
I don't remember what it was,
but it was great.
Bunch of rich Vos and I were on the same show and I look at Jay and I,
and I watched him do crowd work and g big Jay,
his crowd work is impeccable.
I do good crowd work.
I'm a really good cow work Crowdwork guy.
Not like big J.
Big j can do it for a living for the rest of his life and never write material.
He's that fucking good.
He does it all the time to use Joe.
I'm telling you,
watch big J do crowd work
and like,
I don't know if you,
I don't know how you do it the way I do,
but like I go to Kroger corn,
I want to do it.
I don't just do it all the time.
Right.
Man,
he fucking destroyed.
And I,
and I literally looked at him and I was like,
I was so enviously proud of him.
Like going big.
You made you,
you told your own show.
You're doing just what I already did,
but we crowd work what your thing is.
And I look at those guys and you're right.
I think I do look at them and think,
well,
I know Ari's of different beast.
He answers to nobody.
He wants to do his own fucking thing to take a year off from standup.
He'll do it.
He didn't give a fuck.
I'm envious of that and that in that like
it's good.
It's kind of beef.
It's got to feel really good to be untethered.
Yeah.
Like to,
to be like,
you know what man,
I got no fears.
Not to say I,
I'm,
I'm fucking filled with fears.
Everyone knows that.
But like I've got no fears,
uh,
do my thing.
Uh,
I'll uh,
and,
and like I remember right,
like we were having a conversation about notes,
comedy central's given and Ari's take was well the wrong,
but just so impervious to critique the wrong,
I know what I'm doing,
but just almost like Winston Churchill like walking down the street
problem when you have a vision for a show,
then a bunch of people come along and they have their own vision and they tried
to get the greasy little fingers on your vision and change it and add their
little TJ's to the fucking soup.
Yeah.
It's,
and I told him,
I told him,
I told him my notes did I just gotten from the network from comedy central.
Yeah.
It was like,
don't do it.
But it was like I felt like going,
it's
no good to do something that's your,
you collaborate creatively when you do one of those things with people that
aren't creative.
Like they might be creative but they're not stand up comics.
So if they're telling a standup comic,
like you have a vision of what you want it to be and they're telling you that
you're wrong,
you should do it a different way,
that's going to be a disaster.
Every time I experienced that on the man show we,
we got in the most fucking insane arguments over nonsense where Doug would come
into the room pulling his hair and you'd be like,
I can't fucking believe this is something we're arguing over.
Like,
and I would go,
what are they saying?
And he would tell me what they were saying.
Well that can't be real.
That's really what it is.
One of them,
I think I've told this before,
but we had a game show called make me hard.
We'd have a bunch of different things happen.
The guy had a box over his dick with a light would go on when he got a boner.
So we'd have like midgets eaten.
Banana is Ding,
Ding,
Ding.
You know,
it's really stupid.
But um,
they didn't,
they wouldn't let us use hard.
We had to call it stiff,
uh,
crying argument,
like crying.
Like it's,
it's,
it's gone too far.
Like what,
what is this?
When Joey Diaz,
we had Joey Diaz introduce us and Joey Diaz came out naked with timberlands on
let's get this party started.
That was the beginning of every episode.
That's what we wanted to do.
They were literally crying executives,
female executives crying.
How was that and pan show?
How was it?
How was that funny?
It's not funny tears and I'm like,
I can't even believe I'm having this conversation.
I go,
how about we do that?
So we did two ways.
I go,
we'll do the normal way first.
We'll have them introduce us.
Normal.
I go and then we'll do it our way.
We'll,
we'll Joe will come out naked.
So we do the normal way.
All right,
we're going to do a second.
Take the,
the,
he fucking kicked the door up and let's get this party started.
They go ape shit.
People are falling out of their chairs.
It's hilarious.
You know,
and he introduces
us,
Doug Stein home and Joe,
Oh God.
And the place goes ape shit.
The fucking room changes.
And I looked at the lady,
I went,
see that's funny.
Like don't tell me what's funny.
He might,
you don't think it's funny.
You want everything to be all clever.
Like it would work really great at the UCB and everybody would golf clap.
That's bullshit.
You want props for putting together a really smart and diverse show.
Like that's not what we're here to do.
We're here to just make the shit that we think is going to be the funniest.
And we can't do that with you.
You're an albatross,
you're a bundle of wood,
you're a burden.
Some woman,
that's a burden.
100% and it didn't,
it just so happened that she was a woman.
It was a guy that was crying.
I would smack him.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
the I think,
I dunno.
Yeah,
that's not good.
That's why the youtube option is the best option or an online option is the best
option.
That's why podcasts are so superior,
a form of expression than anything you're ever going to find on network
television because whether it's good or whether it's bad,
it's ultimately all coming from you.
100%.
Dude,
you,
uh,
we had this conversation another day,
but the,
um,
creating your own content,
putting your own content out there and making her own content despite what you
may believe your content is.
I woke up this morning,
I got a text tweet from some guy and he was like,
hey man,
I haven't had a bird cast it a week,
like,
what's going on?
And I was like,
ah,
fuck it.
And I hit like,
you know,
uh,
I'll get on it.
I'm doing Rogan today.
Enjoy that.
And then all of a sudden I was like,
fuck it man.
I can get up and go to the man cave and banging on a podcast,
get up,
fucking start talking,
incorporate my vlog.
Go Out,
get the girls donuts podcast,
the whole thing.
Talk to the people at [inaudible] and it's like you're creating your own content
is,
is being the owner of your own shit is where the future is.
It is,
but there are places that will let you do your thing and that's where Netflix is
right now.
Yeah.
He'll bird just,
he has a show coming out December 18th it's calledF is for family.
His experience with them has been amazing.
And him talking about his experience with them and creating that show,
he's like,
they left me alone.
You know,
they,
they just let me do the best show that I could do.
He brought on a bunch of great people,
great voice actors,
great writers,
and he put together this fucking bang,
an animated show that's going to be killer.
It just let him be himself.
They let him do his thing.
They feel they're fucking getting it and they're [inaudible] how soon until
they,
how soon until they get so recognized that that fucking 2020 does a piece on
Netflix taking over public television or regular television and then exact start
flooding into next flicks.
And now it just becomes that from comedy central,
from NBC,
from those e.
The real problem is those people that were in the original networks,
those dinosaurs,
those motherfuckers on CBS and NBC and ABC,
they're with soap
operas there dealing with nonsense to dealing with the fucking,
the multi camera shoot sitcoms.
Ha.
You know.
Well who could possibly do that door cakes in whoop prat fall.
Oh it's Kramer.
You know what somebody did the other day,
somebody put out,
um,
a bunch of outtakes from Seinfeld and you got to see like we're [inaudible]
Kramer.
Oh he fucking sizzled.
If anyone was like laughing,
he would be like,
oh my God.
He was a hated working on news radio,
news radio.
We fucking like,
I did a scene with Andy Dick where I think we probably broke like 10 times.
It was there like 10 times to get through it because Andy was so funny.
Like we do the things I would,
I would bite myself,
I'd bite the inside of my mouth to get to hurt.
So I wouldn't laugh.
I would do all sorts of different things so that I wouldn't crack up.
But you,
you're going to,
if it's a funny show,
you're gonna,
you're gonna Laugh.
I could've never done news radio.
I was watching the videos.
It's looked like he didn't give a fuck about the scene.
He was waiting for his moment and he's waiting for his time to come in and shine
and he didn't care that,
you know,
with Julia Louise Dreyfus and Jerry Seinfeld for laughing,
they're all laughing and yucking it up.
He didn't want to be a part of that.
He just wanted to do his thing.
Yup.
If you watch it,
you watch him just go and like,
not even joking like,
oh,
stop it.
Stop it.
You're ruining this.
Like he fucking seems like they all had some weird things going on.
Like George George's wife who died in this show died because they,
she,
he didn't like her,
like acting with her.
He's like,
she sucks.
So they killed her off.
Really?
Yeah.
I should have that is possible though,
man.
You could have a husband or a wife on a show and the there are a Goddamn
nightmare and you're stuck with those people.
That's a five years,
dude.
That's a real problem.
I had a friend who did a sitcom and he had like a girlfriend on a sitcom that
was supposed to be,
and he was like,
I fucking hate her.
Like she's so she's such a cunt,
like,
and he didn't know what to do.
Fortunately it didn't last.
But they,
they have issues like that and you can,
you could run into issues like,
and also people change with success.
Like the show starts getting really good and then they want a lot of money.
I've heard,
I've heard those crazy stories of people coming in to renegotiate and plopping
their feet up on the executives desks and just letting them know they're the
center of the show.
I'll never be that guy.
I know those guys,
man.
I know a guy who got his whole show canceled because he said some nasty shit to
an executive that was a woman.
He literally said the,
the,
the to paraphrase,
um,
I am the creative genius behind the show and you are a dumb cunt.
That was his words.
Wow.
And they went,
that's a wrap.
They cancel the show the next day and he was only like a few episodes away from
syndication.
You'll never see that show in syndication.
I can't,
I'll tell you after the show's over afterwards over,
I'll tell you,
I don't want to shit on the guy,
but it's a publicly known that he's,
you know,
he's insane.
But the,
I think it's also like why did you become an actor in the first place?
Why did you become a standup for a lot of people's,
they want validation because they were rejected and they have this hole in their
soul.
They need to fill up with love and intention and they,
they didn't get enough of it when they were developing.
So they have this overwhelming mall.
There's a need,
there's a gaping volcano that just swallows couches and more and they just need
attention.
He can't fill that fucker up.
And then once they get what they always wanted and they're still not happy,
they don't know what the fuck to do and a lot of them become tyrants.
But here's the problem.
I don't think I,
what percentage of that group do you think does that that cause I got a little
bit of that fucking sink hole.
Like I'm a stand up.
I bloody does goal.
That's what gets you into the game.
I have no interest in,
and we were talking about this before you walked in.
I have no interest in um,
propaganda or,
or being famous,
being famous for the sake of being famous.
Although I'll fuck around with the concept of it.
I have no like,
I don't want to be Kim Kardashian.
I'd,
I'd rather be a respected stand up.
So what's the difference then between that fucking that,
that sinkhole,
that sucking in all,
all of you versus like us guys who I really love the art form.
I really love
differences between like Larry David and Kramer,
like Larry David.
Is it creative,
brilliant man.
And he's genius.
That show curb your enthusiasm is fucking genius.
And it's all him poking fun at himself and finding the best possible comedic
angle of everything.
It's hilarious.
He's always the loser in every episode.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's God damn.
It's a brilliant,
brilliant show and he by all accounts is a very level guy like very intelligent
is not need.
He just wants to do the best work he can do and brilliant.
Brilliant.
Absolutely brilliant.
That's the difference between a guy like him and a guy like Kramer and my
thoughts on Kramer only from watching him do stand up because I was there.
It was terrible.
I wasn't a guy that was into Seinfeld for whatever reason.
I never watched that show.
I only watched a couple episodes of it ever and it was a good show.
It's just there was only so many things you can watch,
you know and you get when you have south park or married with children or
whatever the fuck it is on your plate that you watch a lot of,
you can only watch so many shows.
For whatever reason.
Seinfeld wasn't the show that I watched all the time,
although the ones that I did watch were always really hilarious,
but I got to see him do standup at the store and he was fucking awful.
It was like a guy who had nothing prepared and just went up there with like a
reputation and some pratfalls and it didn't make any sense.
Like it wasn't like he was trying to work out some bits.
Like you'll see a guy come in and try to work out some shit and like even like a
famous person will come in like a Paul riser or something like that will come
into a club and they'll try to work out some shit.
Son.
When he was doing and we use,
we was doing,
it was just,
didn't make any sense.
I saw him at the Improv like the weekend before,
the weekend before the disaster disaster and it was an uncomfortable,
it was bad.
Like you literally,
he felony lander on his glass and broke his class.
Like he did like a prat fall and broke his glasses and all,
I remember thinking this,
did he just cut his hip?
Like is he going to be bleeding now or it was like legit falls.
Uh,
I dunno.
Yeah.
I called Joe up that night and Mike,
you got to see Kramer's on stage right now.
He's acting all fucked up like he seems like he's on something.
He's with some girl that she's wasted two and then he got offstage,
went to laugh factory.
It all happened.
Jamie ran across the street with TMZ with the video.
Bret Ernst was there,
came over to the store after,
cause I got there at the comedy store right after he had gone wacky at the
comedy store and there was a buzz around and Brian called me up and bunch of
other people were talking about how fucking coked up he was.
And so then he went down the laugh factory and had his meltdown and Brent earns
was there and saw it.
He came back to the story.
He's like,
Yo,
you ain't going to boot.
You know Brett hurt Fred talks.
He was like,
Yo,
you ain't gonna believe how fucking crazy Kramer God,
the laced Adidas with the fucking full tracksuit on dropping bombs like a
motherfucker.
I go,
no.
He goes,
all,
yeah,
these black kids were heckling him and he starts dropping n bombs.
And I'm like,
no.
I like,
yeah,
I go,
was it funny?
He goes,
no,
no.
It wasn't funny.
He was like,
it's funny now
and then Monday it hit and it was the first instance of a video of someone kept
being captured doing something like crazy like that and then putting it on the
Internet and it just ruining that person destroying them.
Yeah.
Here's the night when I called you.
That's what I think the baby phase,
Bryan Kramer,
Caesar.
That's hilarious.
Babyface,
Brian and Kramer.
Uh,
that was the first.
So,
so true.
See if you can,
what are the top five instances of cameras coming out of this at a comedy club
that a comic that had to do a Monday morning,
Mia Copa.
Cause you got Kramer,
who is the other ones?
We got tosh but Taj didn't really do a mia culpa.
He even,
he even him,
his apology,
first of all,
that woman did not record it.
No one recorded it.
That's part of the problem was her version of the facts were completely
distorted.
So then you,
you disregard,
she wrote a whole blog about her heckling and his response to her heckled.
That's essentially what happened.
But,
but he acknowledged that he did.
He definitely acknowledge it,
but it was right there.
Like,
here's the here and I'll,
I'll try to whittle it down to this.
What is the difference then between like Daniel Tosh and Tracy Morgan and Patton
Oswald,
acknowledging there they're getting fucking blogged about versus Michael Kramer.
Is it the fear,
the culture of fear?
What did Patton Oswald do?
Cotton Oswald,
uh,
someone
was videotaping and when he yelled at her at the whatchamacallit and,
uh,
and he said,
shut up.
And then he kicked her out and he was a dick to her and then she had to leave
and then he had to just someone Google Patton Oswald.
Man,
we don't need to.
We don't do,
it's okay.
Yeah.
I think patent Jamie and cut my camera.
Cut The camera.
Bert Kreischer smoking marijuana caught screen camera.
This is,
um,
as Joey Diaz was,
hey,
this is not pedophile.
Small town with the church.
So yeah,
but,
but like,
so I count Tracy Morgan and Patton Oswald and Daniel Tosh and the,
and the Michael Kramer Shit,
right.
Dave Chappelle has a,
maybe have it as a solution to all this.
Well,
Hannibal came up with a solution first.
He started using it after the bill Cosby thing.
That bag,
you can give a bag to people and they put their cell phones in it so they can't
record while they're in there and they saw but how many fucking,
what if they have a cell phone?
Their sock,
you're gonna check their whole body or cell phones.
I think like they're talking about big theaters that Chappelle would be and
where they would have the,
you know,
the security that the metal detectors you have to has metal detectors at
theaters.
You know,
UFC has,
I'm like,
I'll have them in big theaters nowadays.
Arena though,
most of the theaters that we perform it,
like if I perform at a place that's got 3000 seats or something like that,
they don't have metal detectors do that.
Have you ever walked through the door,
walk to the door?
He denied a second ego.
Ego's a death metal,
you know,
that that kind of arena place probably has,
security and stuff like that.
I'm much time do we have left?
Do I have another time for another drink?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
I want him to drink.
It's only four o'clock oh,
perfect bird.
Malvo fucking bird was saying that he got to a point where he was drinking
about fucking Brian.
I told you when I said that these are secrets.
No,
I didn't say that.
I didn't say the rest of it.
Yeah,
you started stupid.
Jamie fucking jump in secret secrets are no fun and I said that was a secret.
I said,
I don't like to share everything because sometimes I wasn't going to say that.
And bonds are too honest and they don't go like they don't like,
like all you guys are very honest.
You don't,
you don't have that.
You have my wife's thing if you want to,
if you want to feel better about yourself,
talk to Jamie and fucking Brian.
If you want to hear the truth and the brutal truth,
talk to you.
Joey are your fucking buns.
And so yes,
I was getting to a point where I was drinking a thing of not a handle of Tito's,
but a bottle of Tito's at night on the road.
That wasn't when I was was going to say that.
You say
that is what at least full shit.
Yeah.
So and also at the fucking Doug Stan hope lump in my stomach or a lump
like a hernia.
Yeah,
I think so.
Does it like when you,
you flex,
does your,
your intestines pop out?
Yeah,
I got fixed.
I know I can,
it's not that big a deal.
I don't know if it's facts.
I'm so fat right now.
I don't know if it's,
how does it poke out?
I uh,
I tried sitting up in bed to the day and I just noticed that my stomach,
I had like what?
It looked
like a sale in my center,
my stomach.
So I was like,
and I know dog showed it to me.
Sale tags got like three of them.
Doug's got a little different than mine,
but I told her yes,
I texted Doug right away and was like,
hey man,
I think I got that thing you got.
And Doug was like,
ah.
I hung out with the doctor.
It's fine.
I hung out with a doctor.
It was a gynecologist.
Doug's crazy last week.
That's right.
We're talking about that.
I love,
I got in here.
I say this and I know there's a lot of crossover fans.
If you are a broken fan and you're not listening to Doug's podcast,
you're missing out a huge portion of,
of just of what a podcast should be.
His podcast is so fucking good.
He's great at everything.
He's great at fucking everything,
but man,
his podcast is so bummed out that he lives in the middle of nowhere.
I'm thinking about taking a road trip to visit.
Memorable to do a Superbowl party.
Yeah,
just to roll it out because it's not that big.
It's not that big anymore.
What are you talking about?
It's going to be,
now we're talking about it right now on a podcast maybe there he released the
address online.
What if?
What if I go,
I'm going to,
then it's going to compound.
They're going to get another hundred people.
It'd be chaos.
His treats would be overrun with retards.
Ears.
Let me see if I can get as a dress.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Here's Stan hopes,
ear stand,
hopes reply.
Nah.
I've successfully ignored it for quite a while and it's actually,
and I actually had a doctor say that he's ignored his for 30 years.
Then I wrote back to exactly what I wanted to see.
It's fine,
unless you plan on lifting anything.
If you want to carry a sand bag up a hill,
you might have a problem with that thing cause it'll tear further and is it your
stomach wall?
Terrorists.
Further,
your intestines will poke out more and the whole couldn't get bigger depending
on how much you strained yourself.
Sure.
You can get just to get it fixed.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I,
I'm going to get to a base level.
Let me give to like two 30 and see where I'm at.
Okay.
How about just get it checked out?
I could just get to two 30 just go get a doctor to look at it.
They'll probably be able to tell you right away and then you can go,
oh,
okay.
It's nothing when I'm two 30 I'll do that.
It's got this thing,
Huh?
That's the number two 30 I get to two 30 though.
Health checks until two 30 I'm talking no health techs who rolls into a health
check fucking like Alan healthy.
Have you ever been on a horse because you're not allowed to ride a horse over
225 pounds.
So I've been on a lot of horses.
I've sprinted on horses.
Wow.
That's a red bottle out to ride on a horse.
Horses can't go over 225 pounds.
Just like giant horse.
I didn't know that.
I ran up through Texas.
What about those Budweiser horses?
Their biggest fuck.
You can totally ride that bitch like Conan the barbarian,
the new game of Thrones horses.
That's cool course.
I would seem to me that that horse kid like take me,
well,
I'm only 200 but if I was to 20 I would think a horse could take me.
No problem.
Those big giant horses,
they can take like three or four.
I bet those giant clydesdale looking things.
She'll tear Burt's.
You're been in front of one of those things in real life.
Oh yeah.
Oh my God.
There's so big like their muscles and like you think about the fact that this
thing just lets you climb on its back and it runs.
Don't get me started.
Horses are incredible,
man.
I laid in bed with my dogs last night and I thought,
oh,
I thought how fucking cool.
I think that's in the Bible.
Oh nevermind.
I go with the story.
I call her.
How cool,
how cool is it to like like get in bed with two warriors who are ready to go to
fucking battle for you if someone rolls in the bedroom.
I was like,
I really felt like Jon snow.
Like it was like,
it's fine.
I was like,
man,
I'm sitting here with Priscilla.
Mona is a little shit dog,
but Priscilla who's like 130 pounds just sitting there just at my leg,
just staring at the door,
sleeping face to the door.
Any noise made.
She's up and willing to die for me.
I thought,
how cool is it?
Like my wife would never do that.
Female dogs are super protective.
They're really good at that.
How many,
how many pimples did you lay in bed with at one time?
I had three in bed at one time.
Who fucks?
Okay.
Think about how,
how defensible that is.
No,
but the three ones,
what's your favorite to come on?
Who,
which ones got balls and out here know
who could fuck with that bedroom?
You got three pimples and you and a bed.
Like with guns,
I might say great
equalizers,
guns,
the great equalizer.
I need to get a gun.
And it's about time.
It's a good goal for everybody.
Is scared of people thinking.
Now when you have like the San Bernardino thing that happened is that people are
just going to be ready and armed and,
and we're going to turn into some sort of a,
a military state.
I mean,
how many of these things can that,
you know,
two of them happen yesterday.
Here's another weird thing.
Most people don't know that there was a second arm mass shooting and killing and
Georgia.
What?
Uh,
yeah,
it was near Atlanta on the same day,
same day.
There was a four people were killed in Georgia,
I think.
Was it in Atlanta?
Yeah,
right.
It was in Atlanta.
You know,
I,
it's one of those things that I do not know if there was a fucking solution for.
It's,
it's one of those weird things where you look at the amount of guns that exist.
You look at the amount of people that there are e mount of disenfranchised
people with mental illnesses.
The amount of people that are religious fanatics,
the amount of people that are just fucking bat shit crazy.
And when you deal with 350 million people,
which is I think what the United States is now,
somewhere between 300 and 350 you're going to,
you're going to have a certain amount of nutty fucking people.
Man.
It's this almost no avoiding it.
There's so much pressure and stress and life is difficult for you're,
you're a successful guy with three TV shows and you're talking about how much
you have to drink to be on a plane.
It talking about anxiety that you getting a hotel room and you're a successful
standup comedian and a television host of three fucking shows you,
your life has balling.
You've got a beautiful wife,
you have a great family,
you're hilarious.
You're a good guy.
It's like everything is in place and you still freak out.
Imagine some guy who's married to some monster who works for a tyrant,
who lives in a Shithole,
whose every day just look at this crime and flat tires and stealing and breaking
and entering,
and that's his life every day,
all day constantly.
And there's a lot of people like that out there,
man.
There's a lot of people that don't get any love.
There's,
they have no place in their life where it feels like they're making a
connection.
They've missed,
they've been slammed in the walls at every term.
They have a dumb job.
They don't give a fuck about that a robot can do.
They're idiots and they just realize it and they're fucking horrified and
they're angry and they're,
they're programming from birth to today has been nothing but dog shit by Shitty
parents and shitty circumstances and shitty genetics,
shitty neighborhood,
shitty life experiences,
bullying,
rape,
molestation,
alcoholism,
racism,
constantly over and over and over and over and over and over.
And they somehow survive.
To get to the point where they get their hands on a gun.
That's what we're dealing with.
We're dealing with is humans freaking out and finding a way to kill the humans
to focus on the mechanism in which they're doing that with.
We're missing a giant piece of the puzzle.
There's too many fucking guns for sure.
It's too easy to get a gun for sure.
You should have,
look,
I have guns.
You should have to take tests.
Okay?
You should have to be some very stringent requirements on your capabilities.
We,
we,
we should know exactly how you do know what the safety is.
Do you know what's a safe way to point the gun?
Do you know how to load it correctly?
Do you know how to clean it?
You clean it,
but you just have this ultimate weapon of destruction and you don't have to have
any knowledge of how to use it at all.
But to have a car,
you have to show that you could turn,
you could hit the brakes,
you can hit the blinkers.
You have to show all of this competency.
You have to host,
show all this knowledge of all the laws and all the rules.
You don't need to show none of that thing to get a gun.
All you have to do is just not be a criminal.
That's all I have to do.
Don't be a criminal.
Are you a criminal?
We're going to do a little check on you,
Mr. Crusher.
Oh,
you're not a criminal,
but here's your gun.
Okay,
question number two.
Are you an idiot?
Are you,
and who's to decide who's to decide?
Who the fuck are you?
Cause I'm an idiot too.
A lot of people,
I would say a lot of people are idiots and they would be it.
It's to me and to them,
there'd be some people that they know that would be stupid as fuck with his
levels of people.
You know?
And you and I are not at the top.
We're just not.
There's people out there that invented Wifi
and they're using lasers to give us fucking satellite communication and all the
crazy shit that you and I know of that we could never invent on our own.
There's some people out of their way fucking smarter than us,
dude,
and they're making that shit.
That's the reality of life.
Oh yeah.
They're a little too high for this conversation.
Too High,
too high,
too high to break it down.
I was like,
you know what scares me the most about the San Bernardino killing?
Why is it didn't surprise me that that's what scares me the most.
What scares me the most is like,
oh,
another one.
It seems like almost every day now.
Like I like every day it's been something almost,
well,
they have that calendar out that the calendar shows that it's like literally 13
days a month that there's mass shootings,
isis advent calendar.
Is that what it is for real?
Oh,
I maybe I don't do enough research,
but like it just seems so crazy.
Well,
here's the problem is exactly what you've said is I love,
I agree.
Something's wrong with our system,
with the guns there,
that something needs to be done.
Something needs to be changed because we have a lot of fucking mass killings.
And,
and from what I hear from Jim Jefferies Act,
there's done in Australia,
well they took the guns away.
They had a mass killing,
I think quite a while.
Jim Jefferies want to say was in the eighties Jim Jefferies has a very,
uh,
viral bit that every time there's a mass shooting,
he gets another 12 million views.
And I,
and I,
and I love Jim,
I'm not shitting on it,
but like,
but like it is about that fact.
There was one mass shooting and they all took their guns back and they've never
had another killing mass shooting Australia.
Well,
you're dealing with a place that has way less people.
Here's Australia,
20 million people and mostly in two cities.
There's very few people.
So was that his leg,
country of Australia is pretty massive as well.
Right?
It's gigantic.
It's the same size as the contiguous.
That's how they say it.
Continuous or continuous thought the entirety of the United States of America.
Same size,
same size essentially.
And they've got the politicians about laying there.
Yeah.
Less.
Less than La.
Holy Shit.
He's got 20 million people plus Mexicans.
Okay.
Let's be honest.
What are the real numbers?
Oh,
I was going to be through the phone.
I love Mexicans.
I'm not hating on illegal immigrants.
I love people that are willing,
documented workers,
whatever you want to call them.
I call them Mexicans.
I love people that have the courage to do something illegal to better their
life.
Yeah.
And I think a lot of them are great.
I think a lot of them aren't.
They embody what America's supposed to be.
American is supposed to be this place where you can go and you could make it,
you know this,
this spot where it's freedom.
You don't,
you don't get suppressed by just fucking generation after generation of people
doing it wrong.
You can get the fuck out of Mexico and Woo.
Ah,
and you get to America and just hustle.
Just go to work.
Just,
just go after it.
It's jobs out there.
Get them.
But then what about the Syrian refugees?
Yeah,
man,
it's good to bullshit.
Fucking doesn't want them.
Well listen,
it's against our question.
That's against what,
what makes us up could not welcome.
Exactly.
First of all,
those are the people that are leaving the bad people.
Like where are we?
Assuming that everybody over there is bad.
You can't do that because then that's a self fulfilling prophecy.
If you won't let them in and you don't treat that,
I give them open arms like just because they're Muslims.
That's ridiculous.
Oh,
hold on.
Some of this,
how the attackers in Paris were Syrian refugees,
so I'm not upset.
Yeah,
well a hundred percent for whatever I fucking,
yeah,
I mean I don't,
I don't know.
I think what they got to look out for his young radicalized single men,
that's what the entirety of this movement seems to be as he's radicalized young,
younger men.
Like that Jihadi John Guy was like a former rapper from England and he joined
Isis.
Like there's a lot of people that are joining this.
It's very strange,
dude.
It's very strange.
Like girls are joining and they're getting killed.
You know,
one,
one of the girls recently got beaten to death and another one got murdered.
It's like,
what is going on?
I thought it was closeted homosexuals.
At first I thought tariffs were,
I thought they were all just closeted homosexual come after him.
Kreischer don't say my worried about comp.
You've worried about comedy central,
but you know worried about saying that.
That's hilarious.
You've been drawing Muhammad.
Okay.
That's hilarious.
A lot of like,
like like homosexuality so kept down there like maybe they're just guys that are
fucking,
no,
I don't think that's what it is.
Sitting in a cave like,
hey man,
I call blow you and the guys are like,
what?
And he's like,
I saw it blow up.
Let's go blow each other up.
Oh no dairy you.
It's just radical ideologies,
man.
That's all it is.
The idea,
this is the fact that there could be anything out there,
anything,
call it whatever you want.
Don't call it,
don't even call it a name.
Just think about whatever it is,
the energy and the influence that leads someone to go shooting a bunch of random
people.
I think one of the problems with labeling things when we start saying,
oh,
this was a mass shooting,
this was a religious killing.
This was a jihadi cell.
This was,
we'd give it all these titles and names,
but just separate yourself from culture,
like pretend you're an alien or something and you're looking at this,
you're looking at this from afar and you're just looking at this as some sort of
an equation or something like that.
You're watching what's going down,
like what is it,
what's going down?
Like what is it that can,
these things down here can convince themselves by manipulation of communication.
So they've got a way to talk to each other.
They've got a way to relay ideas and they've got a way to reinforce opinions and
ideas later,
thousands of years old,
and they got a way that
it's so strong that it can make some of them explode and just go around,
kill random people and think somehow or another they're doing it for the greater
good.
So they'll,
through this I this ancient ideology,
this is whatever it is,
call it whatever you want,
but through through this influenced by some people's minds that's projected
somehow or another into another person's mind.
And it convinces that person to kill random people.
Forget about what you call it.
Forget about whether it's Islam or Christianity or Mormon is or Scientology.
Forget the names,
forget it.
Just forget even the language that has been spoken in,
look at it in terms of what are the noises that are made by the humans that
create the reaction and one of those norms is with those noise.
What are those words?
One of those written things represent,
they represent like,
oh,
like almost like a living idea,
a living idea that wants to express itself like through the filter of the
language and the culture.
Like what is it?
What is it that causes something to want to get people to go after?
People that are opposed to this idea or that have differing ideas and killed
them.
Just killed them by parenting.
It's all bad parenting.
Isis is the worst parenting in the road.
If you think about it,
that's what it is.
The right and we might,
it just might be a point to that.
Yeah,
there might be a point to it.
It will to all the ancient cultures,
right?
Like if you think about people that made a break,
like those are the ones that seem to be the healthiest.
Like the Australians.
They made a break from England.
They got in a boat,
they got kicked out there,
a prison colony.
Right.
So they made him get in a boat,
go over to Australia and live there.
Right.
That's essentially how Australia started.
Yeah,
but look at them.
The fucking amazing.
Their cities are incredible.
The people are cool as fuck.
They're generally like really easy to talk to and friendly.
They're smart.
Like,
dude,
Melbourne was amazing.
It's like a like almost didn't want to tell people about it.
I'm almost over here.
I'm like,
Whoa,
this is,
where else is there like this in the world?
Oh Dude.
Astra Australia is like your growth,
your girlfriends,
younger,
hotter sister.
You sit down at Thanksgiving and you're like,
mother Fucker,
I didn't know she was coming,
but look what it is.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a civilization that emerged or culture that emerged out of a break from an
old culture.
They started,
they kind of had a reset and they started fresh.
The people that are stuck in the spots that are super ancient.
You're dealing with this pattern repeating itself over and over again.
It's hard to break.
So what you're saying is like all my friends that when I go down to Tampa,
then they're left Tampa and they're kind of still using racial slurs.
What that is is on a global scale,
people that have never left that area for thousands of years exactly is he just,
it's just ignorance.
So your experience begets
a kind of openmindedness.
Well,
I think that it's just,
it's very difficult to break out of the hive if you're in a hive mind of people
that are essentially thinking the same way they did when Alexander the Great was
around.
It's very,
it's hard.
Like Afghanistan is a perfect example.
There's really only one city.
I mean,
I don't know much about Afghanistan honestly because I really haven't been
there,
but I've talked to many people that have been there,
soldiers that have fought there,
and I've absorbed as much as I could what they were trying to say and tried to
figure it out.
But essentially what it seems like is you have one city and then you have these
strange areas that are controlled by warlords.
Like a lot of them,
they have like these areas where it's not just like,
uh,
like,
like what I'd imagine Iraq to be.
It's insanely mountainous,
insane.
Like just like a small town in,
in,
uh,
say Butler,
Ohio would be a control by a warlord.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No targets do.
Well,
you know,
John Mccain,
I remember this was trying to impart that on,
on uh,
Barack Obama when they were debating when they were running for President Mccain
and Sarah Palin and he said the exact same words that I would just said.
Like that's where I got it from him and initially installed until I started
looking into it and talking to these guys that went over there.
They said it's like the same as when Alexander the Great was around.
And that's what Mccain said.
He said to Obama like,
this is your,
you don't understand Afghanistan.
You're saying we're just going to send troops in there.
You can't just do that like that.
This is like the rocky mountains.
I mean it's fucking crazy.
It's all mountains and these guys were living out there and caves and made these
Taliban guys living in Cains.
You've got these dudes are war lords and they got like 20 wives and then giving
them Viagara to get them to talk.
They give these guys Viagara to rat on the Taliban at.
Really?
Yes.
That's how they would give.
That's how I would get them to talk.
They would give them Viagara.
That sounds like something on the Internet.
That's what we know.
This is one of the government's main uses of bribery or main a main main items
that they would bribe people with.
Yeah,
because he's guys who get like 60 and they got 20 wives,
they can't fuck him anymore.
And then someone,
American GI comes along and he's like,
yeah man,
what do you need dude?
Well you know with,
so let's talk.
We got guns.
You know,
do you need guns?
It's like,
I've got plenty of guns,
my friend.
And they're like,
do you need girls?
I got date twin wives,
my friend I know need you.
I got a blue pill that makes your dick hard.
The stock.
Let's take a lift up at the light.
I'll tell you what I know.
I never liked those motherfuckers.
Little blue pills among the way CIA wins,
friends and Afghanistan.
I thought I was having a stroke that came on so fast.
Look at that.
Afghan chief didn't looked older than a 60 year,
60 odd years and his bearded face bore the creases of a man burden with the
duties as tribal patriarch and husband to for
younger women.
See,
there you go.
They gave him by Hagrid Dude,
they gave him Viagra.
I recently tried real viagara and real Cialis and it's pussy shit compared to
the stuff you get at the gas station and I fucked that shit.
Yo,
you were talking about on one of the podcasts we did recently,
he,
Brian would take these a boner pills that you'd get at a gas station for the
closing bit,
right?
Well,
no,
he had,
you know how you have those things like where there's like a little lighter
container and there's a breath,
mint container and the right when you go to pay at the gas station,
there's like a porn almost where it's like a naked girl getting fucked by.
It's like,
you know,
blue dynamite,
well these things are like a cocktail of steroids and steroids,
Viagara acorns,
things like that.
And then it's,
it's,
what's crazy though is that I,
this guy in a wheelchair recently came to show,
he's a comedian from Chicago.
I can't remember his name right now.
And he goes,
I always hear about the boner post.
Well,
I get them because I'm in a wheelchair and the retard strength,
I want you to like have these.
So he gave me a whole box of them and I took one,
it was like,
oh,
this isn't the retard strength.
Really,
really strong.
Like they're like,
like,
you know that nothing normal level.
Right.
Okay.
That's what that says.
I think he's,
I think he said that really having a hard time understanding what you're saying.
I'm sorry,
I'm stone.
So he gave me the high,
high end versions of them and I took them and being used to the only the kinds
that you get at the store,
they're like really like bitch versions,
like of what you can get at seven 11 for $6.
I just think that what you're getting at seven 11 is a lot of illegal steroids
too.
That's what it is.
Like you're taking something and you're just getting jacked up on testosterone.
Sure.
Maybe.
But I'm saying if you want to,
if you're,
if you're going to fuck like a 21 year old and you're like,
I better do something right here.
I'm just saying go with that one.
That's what I'm saying is like,
I appreciate the,
uh,
the results.
Like I think it sounds like you're right,
it's swollen.
It would be a good idea to get that stuff tested.
Find out exactly what's in it because I guarantee you they're not consistent.
I know,
I know.
And if you're just getting like just random shit from,
who knows where the lesion fake Viagra.
But after looking at 4,000 different reports from the FDA,
they're all just like the worst steroids and it's just a teeny,
but it steroids in your Dick,
you know,
it's not like it's you're pumping it in like a needle in your arm and I'm not a
UFC fighter.
The stronger steroids,
there's some pretty,
well I don't see some of the stronger,
there's some really strong ones that you,
uh,
you eat their orals.
I think one of them,
if I'm not correct,
there's just one.
I knew this bodybuilder guy was insane and he would take some shit called Anna
drawl 50,
which is supposed to be like one of the more liver toxic ones,
but I can't remember whether it was,
um,
whether it was a one you ate or when you
injected,
but the guys that were beyond that,
this,
this buddy of mine,
he took it,
he was a serious body,
but there was also,
uh,
he became a Jiu Jitsu black belt and if saw him now,
you would never believe that he was a serious bodybuilder because he's like
really lean,
almost like a runner.
It's like a tall guy,
like maybe six to really strong,
like super,
super tight grip and great Jujitsu.
But uh,
he was on this stuff,
this antique draw 50 shit.
And he said,
some guy said something to him at a,
at a red light.
And he said he didn't even realize what was happening until he was reaching
through the guy's window,
beating the shit out of him.
Like he sort of like woke up in the middle of beating the shit out of this guy,
parked his car.
Like some guy yelled at,
I'm like,
fuck you old man,
or something like that.
And he snapped and said he didn't even read it.
And that's when he realized like,
okay,
I can't,
I can't be doing this anymore.
Holy Shit.
And he got away with it somehow or another,
he didn't get arrested or I don't know what he did to the guy.
I don't think this was Jujitsu training.
I don't want to say the guy's name,
but I don't think this is when he was training Jujitsu.
So I think it was before,
I think it was just bodybuilding.
Holy Shit.
I,
I think,
and I think that's when you eat.
I think that's an oral one.
So if they took that stuff and put it in his fucking little dick pills that
might have a,
it might have quite significant pop.
You don't Earl scaffold,
you know Earl [inaudible],
he's one of my favorite people ever and I was just on his podcast and he's like
the boner pill.
Qantas Sword.
Like
Michael is the guy just take you to a Kennedy.
Yes.
No,
he just had,
ah,
oh Geez.
Had Tommy Tommy Mars on it,
which is an amazing,
amazing interview.
So I was amazing.
The overstate.
I know it is eye opening,
a really great interview.
It's interesting.
If you're in a comedy,
I wouldn't say it's amazing,
amazing opening eye opening,
how crazy it is.
Well,
that's who we were dealing with for a long time.
Yeah,
that's the number one reason why I came back to the comedy store.
So I was just starting to group that.
I was just on his podcast yesterday.
I was the next person after Tommy,
and that interview made me so mad that I kind of blew up a little bit on on his
podcast,
but what did you really talk about?
Boner pills and you can actually buy the ingredient,
like a lot of ingredients on the Amazon and stuff like that,
that will give you the same results as like a boner pill that are healthy and
stuff like that as like sink.
Can I stop you right here because I don't,
I've never needed it by Agra,
but I have friends that I like you that I can't imagine.
Need Avaya grow or a boat or pill.
What does it do?
Does it?
Oh No.
All I needed something that doesn't make me come as fast.
No.
What?
That's different.
Alcohol.
No,
I meant well,
I'm with my wife.
Like I would love something that made me not climax so quickly.
The hall,
well that doesn't work obviously the last time I find that lasts for three
hours.
Everybody's different.
But what does a biker dude,
is it like,
do you have a problem getting a hard to no,
no,
I don't
Vaso dilator.
It's what's is.
It's banned in the Olympics as a performance enhancing drug because it has a
beneficial effect on athletic performance,
a measurable effect on athletic performance,
and then it has something to do.
I might butcher this,
but with your body's production of nitric oxide,
I think that's what it is.
That stuff that's in like an o two Max and all these comp things and that stuff
apparently has a beneficial effect on a muscle and athletic performance that
nitric oxide stuff.
So you don't need it to,
you can,
you can get it to happen.
Yeah,
but it's not that it doesn't,
what is the way it works?
It's not that like Brian would just automatically get a harder out of nowhere.
It's just like will it,
you'd still have to be in the presence for the girl that you thought was
attractive and you do it.
It's just like you would normally,
you know,
be attractive,
started making out with someone,
but your Dick would get hard as a fucking crow bar.
It's like everything is dialed up to 10 it's like more like a swollen,
like a snake bite or big.
Here's the thing.
Here's the thing is that it's a yes,
your dick is maximized.
But here's the thing is that it,
it's your whole body.
Your whole body is experiencing this.
Like your muscles are experiencing this.
All of your muscles are experiencing this.
It's not just your deck.
That's why it's not my goal.
It doesn't really do anything for you.
Well,
no,
it's not that,
that does not what I'm saying.
If you use it and run,
like if you did exercise and you did something,
you would have like more endurance,
you'd have more work output.
It could benefit you to a point in at least some way,
in a measurable way that the Olympic Committee is like nap.
I don't think so.
And you,
you can't have it in your system.
I know cyclists have used it,
you know?
Um,
if I took one,
I would just feel like a rock star in that my dick was bigger and I could fully
engorged like to the fullest.
See,
I like it.
I like at massage parlor is because you usually are too nervous.
Like where'd that girl is?
Like,
like working and you can't get hard or without touching herself,
you're just laying near your Dick's Grush.
But when you flip over,
you want to have at nice healthy Dick's so she can take care of you.
Right.
And so boner pills really help out.
Like in situations like that where you wouldn't have boner about encouraging
people to take those things,
you don't know who's gonna make the next batch.
This is the reality of having supplements that aren't really,
they're not really examined the,
you just sell them.
You know what the worst thing that happens is someone catches the fact that you
have a prescription drug in there,
like a Cialis or something like that.
And this is according to Aubrey.
I asked him about it and he understands like the,
the rules on things like this and he said that what they do is they essentially
just find you and these people reopen under a different name and they just go
right back at it.
Yeah.
Because they develop a reputation where people like Brian,
no,
they go in,
there's a little thing with the fucking lighters and the breath mints and the
boner pills.
They're right there at that.
Those things work.
That's why they're selling them.
Then they're not placebos.
They fucking work and it's easy to get that stuff from China or wherever the
fuck they get it from Russia.
I don't know whether they got to watch out some of the China,
uh,
fake Viagra and stuff can actually contain like poison recently.
That's what I'm saying,
dude.
That's what I'm saying.
Don't be fucking around with that.
I mean I had some stuff that I can still buy today that makes me trip.
Like I started seeing visuals,
so I stopped with that one.
But I want to know what that,
that one is.
So I've been waiting for the FDA to that one.
That's what Anderson Silva got pop for when he got popped for steroids.
He wasn't taking steroids.
He was taking a Viagra that was like from China.
And when they had made this stuff in the laboratory,
it was somehow or another contaminated by steroids.
And he had to admit this,
but this is,
I know this from people in this camp,
like they were talking about things.
This isn't a made up story.
It's embarrassing and it's crazy.
But it's totally true when you buy stuff like from these random companies and
China,
there are some that do an awesome job of making sure that all of the
ingredients,
whatever you're buying from them are pure.
But there's some that just,
they don't bother to clean out the machinery.
So like if you have a vitamin B 12 and right before you had the vitamin B 12
order,
they had some other stuff in there,
some vitamin C or whatever.
It could easily get mixed up in to a measurable amount and the amount that will
show up in a drug test.
It's possible.
It's totally possible.
100%.
And when you looked at Anderson's results,
like he tested positive before the fight,
like outside of training and then he tested negative like I think at the weigh
ins and then positive or something along those lines.
Then positive after the fight.
It was like a,
it was,
it didn't make any sense.
And they were trying to figure out how,
how was this happening?
Like this doesn't make any sense.
Like the steroids should stay in your system for a longer period of time.
It doesn't make any sense that they would be there at one time,
not be there another time.
Like what was the variable?
And then Anderson had to like come out and have like a press conference and said
that I took this weird Viagara shit and that's why the,
the tests were so odd.
What a weird world it is.
The world of like trying to figure out what you can get away with and what you
can't get away with a beat someone's ass better
wouldn't we were rolled the where you going to fucking figure out that it was
Viagra pills?
Well that's all I went to was like,
I guess he tested it.
What am I allergic to?
Type thing where you're like,
what did I have?
Oh fuck,
I had this indigestion one day.
What was that until was like as a peanuts.
So you're like,
fuck,
it was what a crazy world is.
As you're telling the story,
I couldn't read your shirt and I went,
I don't know if you posted it,
but Roy Jones Jr is easily,
in my opinion,
watching him fight the most beautiful fighter that ever lived.
Yeah,
he's,
I,
if I had to choose my all time favorite boxer,
either be Roy Jones Jr on Mike Tyson.
Those are my two all time favorite boxers.
Tyson's knockout sizzle is fucking phenomenal.
But Roy Jones jr fighting.
Well,
both of them
were just fucking incredible and in a different way.
I mean,
Tyson was incredible and like a violent storm and Roy Jones Jr was just a
virtue.
Whoa.
So who could do shit that nobody else could do and reinvented how to engage Roy
Jones Jr,
you know,
barely threw jabs,
right?
John's would throw a lead left hook that was as fast as anybody else's jab and
he would crack Tudes with that shit off the back leg.
And he would hit dudes and you would see their reaction to the speed of Roy's
punches and they'd be like,
oh my God.
When they realize what a different level he was on.
Like one of my favorite Roy Jones Jr fights was Roy Jones jr versus Vinnie.
Patsy Enza because Vinny Pazienza because yeah,
he was going way up in his weight class.
I mean Vinnie was a much smaller guy and he said,
you know,
he got real big and juiced up and he's,
he's tough as shit,
but he was just too short.
It wasn't built for the weight class.
Vinnie pass came any fast fought Roy Jones and it was the only round ever where
the copy box numbers showed the opponent landing zero punches,
zero.
Roy just lit him up like a Christmas tree and did whatever he wanted to the
point where
Vinny couldn't manage a single punch.
It had never been recorded before.
I don't know if it has sense,
but that's how good Roy Jones was at the time and Roy Jones was beating his ass.
He knocked him down and he turned to the referee saying,
please stop this.
And the referee said,
nope,
keep fighting.
He said,
all right.
So he dove in with an uppercut cracked and like lifting him up in the air and,
and,
and planted them on the ground.
Holy Shit.
He was a fucking,
when he was at his prime dude,
he was a marvel,
a marvel of movement.
Like he had a level of movement to him.
Like you can say that Bernard Hopkins might've been more fundamentally sound or
Julio,
Cesar Chavez might've had like a,
a more uh,
a more gritty in your face game cause Roy would kind of hang on the outside to
pick his shots and decide what he wanted to do when he wanted to do it.
But when it comes to like movement does the best,
however,
nobody moved.
Like that guy,
right?
Jones jr there's a video of him,
this guy throws a punch and he counters with a a right left like a straight
right and oh no,
it was a,
a left hook and a right hand like that.
And he counters with,
it's so fast,
like you can't even believe it's real and it's just like one of those little
quick vine clips and you just watch them go by that and you just,
and the guy's like central nervous system just shut off.
There was a time for a few years.
Well he was just unstoppable force.
I missed it.
I missed it there man.
I was there.
I was watching the whole time.
I couldn't believe it.
He was so much better than everybody else at the time.
So much faster.
It was ridiculous when he fought James Toney,
dude,
he fought James.
Tony does the,
he fought the killer from Detroit.
He fought James Tony who was just a slick boxer with nasty knockout powers.
Tough Shit.
And Roy Jones Jr just showed him another level of movement.
Just another level,
you know?
Yeah.
Dropped his hands.
And then Tony dropped his hands like in response and then Roy leaps in with a
left cook cracks right in the Chin and drop some.
And it was like this,
like,
don't fucking do what I'm doing,
bitch.
Like he was just on such a different level.
How's row?
How Royal House Roy Jones Jr.
I,
it's funny that I say that.
I knew
I was good at
it.
This is him and Vinny Pazienza band.
This was worth around where he gets to that zero.
Yeah,
this is
fourth round.
There's glass jar and the Vinny Pazienza was a tough guy.
He knocked out my friend Dana Rosenblatt,
who is a guy that I used to train with back in the day in Boston under Joe Lake
was they,
uh,
a boxing coach that I knew from back then.
So I was a big fan of any patsy ends.
He's tough as shit,
but he was really like way out of his weight class.
Roy was so much bigger than him,
so that Vinny,
even though he was a big guy because he had all that muscle on him,
his actual frame was nowhere near the frame of Royce,
you know,
he was more like a guy.
He fought a lot of like really tough guys that lower weight class too.
But you look at them there,
he looks almost like a bodybuilder.
He does.
Finney pass.
Uh,
and his training partner came out to a show that I did in,
uh,
New Jersey with Mr Sandman.
I think I want to say.
That's right.
Dude is crazy watching
this.
You forget how fast Roy was.
There's just no one liked him at the time,
man.
And you know,
one of the things that really messed with Roy was that when Roy Nelson was in
his prime,
there was a guy named Gerald Mcclellan and Gerald Mcclellan was,
I want to say he was a light heavyweight champion.
Gerald McClellan.
How do I know that name?
Gerald McClellan was a famous boxer who was a world champion.
I want to say light heavyweight,
but I might,
I might be incorrect.
And Gerald was,
uh,
one of the guys from the Croc Jim under manual Stewart.
Okay.
He was just Merkin people,
man.
He was a nasty,
he was so good.
And he fought this dude named Nigel Benn.
They fought in Italy or in,
uh,
England rather.
And it was his why I believe it was England wild,
crazy ass fight.
And a Nigel Benn went through the ropes in the first round and cheer on
Mcclellan was just putting it on him.
And then later in the fight,
something happened.
Um,
there was like a clash of heads and Nigel Benn went,
or a,
and then Jeremy Mclellan went down to one knee and then he quit the fight and
they were like,
we can't believe this.
The fights over.
And then he collapsed in his corner and he had some serious brain bleeding man
and,
uh,
went to the hospital and they did their best to alleviate it.
But to this day he's blind.
He can't walk.
He's in a wheelchair,
he's all fucked up.
He has a very,
very short
memory of life,
you know,
of a,
of who he was and his capacities been like radically diminished.
Uh,
uh,
but he was,
he was the guy that people were saying one day,
Roy Jones,
Jr and Gerald Mcclellan are going to fight.
It's gonna be crazy.
Cause Jerrel was a monster.
Gerald was a monster and now you know that Gerald got fucked up.
I think it affected Roy Jones.
I think it affected him like psychologically where he realized like,
Hey,
that could happen to that guy.
That can happen to me too,
you know?
And so he fought a lot more smart,
took less risks,
you know?
But how many concussions,
like I said,
I don't know about,
I started this before.
How many concussions do you think is too many?
It's a good question because I've had,
I definitely had seven,
I think.
And he's a grown man.
Has to at least have five
by the time you're 18.
Um,
I definitely had at least by,
but by the time I was 18,
I think I gave one to myself the other day.
I bent down,
I told you about this.
I haven't been down in my happy,
like a sleigh bed thing,
like a wooden thing.
It just cracked my head really hard on the corner and like picking up a shoe,
like,
and I saw the flash of light.
I just laid down.
I'm like,
all right,
I'm not passing or not passing out.
Yeah.
You probably give yourself a concussion.
Um,
I don't know.
You'd have to talk to a test.
I don't know if you had to ballpark it.
Oh,
bar.
I'll ballpark mine that.
I've had a couple for sure.
I've definitely had a couple,
but like I think everyone's had a car.
I mean like I've,
I've had a couple of go to the hospital,
a couple,
you know,
I've had two definitive ones ride to go to a hospital for them.
See the problem with sparring all the time is you get them and you don't know if
you got them or not because you're not going to a doctor.
So there was nights where I would just lay in bed and my head would be
throbbing,
you know,
and I just,
me and some other meat had beaten the fuck out of each other in the gym.
Just doing boxing,
sparring or kickboxing sparring.
Yeah,
that's there.
There had to be a bunch that had to be like three or four in there.
When your heart problem memory,
my memory is excellent.
Yeah.
It's,
and it's only excellent about things I care about though.
I have a,
but that's just my mind.
I just don't,
when I don't give a fuck about something,
like it's gone.
I just don't,
I have developed this over the years.
It's just my,
my,
uh,
style of focusing on things.
If I don't give a fuck about something,
I don't pay any attention to it.
I just can't because I know how,
you know,
I know how my brain works.
So what I know about,
I know about and what I don't give a fuck about.
What was it?
I don't remember.
I don't just don't remember things.
I remember things that are super important,
but it's never like I look at the fucking where my car is.
Oh wait,
where the fuck my car?
No.
Yeah.
Like,
I dunno,
I feel like I've had,
I've definitely feel like I might be on the upside of concussions,
but do you mean by the other gang?
I'm on the higher end of the higher end from,
uh,
um,
if you're not experiencing any problems,
I wouldn't worry about it.
I think experiencing
problems would be pretty obvious.
Yeah.
Once you start having like real problems like memory problems or if you heard of
um,
the guy who was the quarterback for the Chicago bears.
Jim McMann.
Yeah.
For Tinder.
Perry was that the test?
If I could remember his name,
I was trying to remember his name as I was saying it,
but he was the,
uh,
you know,
the star of the Superbowl.
That guy was an animal and now he's all fucked up.
There was a sports illustrated article I read about them when they're talking
about,
uh,
he would just like forget what he was doing.
He'd be in the middle of his house and just not know why he's there or where,
where he's going.
He might have his keys in his hand,
not know where,
where was headed to and he knows he's got something going on and Brett Farve got
that shit coming down the line.
100%,
man,
they all have it.
You're in there in the arena,
you're clashing heads and they came up old school,
those guys came up before they really understood CTE.
They came up right now,
if you're not a hard Norse knows quarterback,
then you're not shit.
What are you going to be fucking Joe Montana?
You're going to be earn your money because you live in Milwaukee.
It's fucking hard sport,
dude.
There's no way around that sport being hard.
You get the biggest super athletes in the world and their sprint in your way
sprint,
and
some of those guys are bigger and stronger and faster than humans have ever been
ever,
and they're trying to get you cause you've got that ball.
Dude.
I couldn't even jump onto my side right now and not get hurt.
Like if they said just jump on your side.
He'll hold a football and jump on your side.
I've broken a rib diving for something and landed on my arm wrong.
In a lot of ways,
you've got to think
like playing football is one of the most courageous sports because at least in a
fight you only have one dude and if you're better than that guy,
you can control the action.
If you understand what's going on,
you can control it to a certain extent.
Yeah.
Like Bernard Hopkins is still fighting into his fifties right?
He's 50 now.
He's still fighting and he's still like at a world class level.
You know he beat some guy when he was 49 for a title.
I mean,
this is insane,
right?
Yeah.
Why does he do that?
He does it because he can control the action.
He controls it like he makes sure that he's in the right position at all times.
He's constantly controlling exactly what's going on.
Dot Hopkins.
Is it only black?
Our wives ever wanted the fuck.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Let's wrap it up.
Everybody.
I'm at the Irma.
This,
you write it down now.
We were.
We were sitting on the couch.
Whoa.
I know hard though.
It's just an interesting guy.
Out of all the guys that she got a named,
it was Bernard Hopkins.
Did you get hard when you thought about it?
No.
No,
not at all.
Give me a Drake.
What does she went?
Lenny Kravitz would,
that'd be intimidating.
I saw his dick.
I can beat it.
So,
oh my God.
Especially with some zinc.
Yeah,
with Lenny.
With those pants,
like that was ridiculous.
What was,
what's hilarious about it was like,
it almost seemed like a Cgi Dick.
Like he came out so perfectly,
I didn't kind
of like half talk.
No,
it went,
hello.
50 tend to have a
jack.
Exactly.
It just jumped out of nowhere.
I mean,
his pants ripped and his dick went,
how I,
yeah.
[inaudible] be better unprepared.
Like I need to prepare mine to present it,
but fucking I saw his dick.
I was like,
I can beat that.
Yeah.
It seemed like it was like a dick radar in some ways.
Like on Facebook,
like all the guys going,
Ooh,
whatever man.
He's got a huge Dick.
And you're like,
oh,
what now we know what your Dick Sizes.
That's what the job was.
Warrior.
They're like,
oh,
they're just saying that because he's black
too.
If he was a white car,
they would just say,
mark his dick did mock it.
I mean,
you heard about Justin Bieber's Dick?
No,
I haven't heard of.
I was day.
Well,
yeah,
he's,
he has a massive hog apparently.
Now you saw it.
Yeah.
Oh,
I googled it.
I looked for Justin Bieber's Dick and then googled.
How old is Justin Bieber?
Sort Dick,
but like,
yeah,
apparently there's pictures of him on a beach naked and he's fucking hung like a
horse.
No one says a fucking word,
but everyone says Lenny Kravitz,
little tiny Dick.
There's massive fucking bullshit,
man.
Very.
You seem angry cause he seem angry.
How much time we have left in the podcast?
I was like seven minutes left.
Come on.
Why so upset.
I'm no,
I'm not upset.
I'm just,
I'm not.
There's no fucking,
I have no connection to either were Dick.
I'm just saying it seems like a weird thing to have on your mind.
It's the point.
I mean you're,
you know,
beepers,
deck father,
you have children,
you've been traveling the world.
You were on a moped in Vietnam and a rice patty and we were talking on a cell
phone,
the other side of the world.
These are like amazing,
amazing experiences.
Hey,
you are his dick is chuck.
I'm a grassroots guy.
Do you hate the color of your deck?
I wish I could.
I always say made Dick Cream to jerk off with so that it was like Shane,
your Dick to a perfect side body feel like this.
Like Oh yeah,
I've actually thought about as an a Avention Dick for real.
I'm dead serious.
Wow.
Like you go into a dermatologist and you're like,
hey,
let's,
what if we had like a,
like a stripping material just to like fucking make it perfect and you give it
to a guy,
hey,
once a month jack off of this new Dick will be like fucking captain Griffin.
Brand new.
Yeah,
but I think you would miss your veins,
right?
Yeah.
If you had just like a smooth,
weird fake cylinder looking deck,
even if it felt good like an Andy Warhol Dick,
what do you prefer?
Here's perfect example.
Do you prefer big stretched out fake tits or big real tits?
Oh,
big,
real big.
Why?
Because a real cause when you've tried to go to the nipple,
it slips away from you.
Like someone tried to get to a different arcade,
grabs your dick and it feels like a FedEx tube
this perfectly round and smooth and you just want to fucking stick a fishing rod
in there.
I said a tube for mailing things.
That's not a dick.
Dick's,
you're supposed to be uneven.
Just like nipples.
Like if,
if you got like if you look at a girl's nipple,
it's the,
if you get really close to it,
like a magnifying glass,
it's chaos.
It's all sorts of stuff going on there.
The skin is all crazy.
Like,
like the butt of an artichoke artichoke heart mark and says loose Morgan Freeman
moles or whatever.
That's fine.
Smalls are these little dots all around it,
you know?
But it's beautiful in its imperfection.
That's like half of the thrill of it.
If it was just completely doll,
like and smooth on the nipple and then smooth and the area,
oh La and then the breasts where there's no veins,
there was it,
it was just smooth,
like a,
like a bowl of Jello,
like a Broadway show.
He said,
wow,
like a fucking robot man.
You know we didn't want that.
You wouldn't want that.
Might look at it though.
No,
am I not that girls would call clean.
Roughly half of the thing about sex is animalistic man.
The dirtiness,
the humiliation.
Now
what are we going to wrap this up?
I'm just,
he sweating
so fucked up.
You shouldn't be talking on the air.
That's it.
Nothing bad has been said.
Beautiful.
Talking about aerial is I love dark points.
No,
no,
no.
I like uh,
I like my wife is like a high pink.
I like that.
It just seems,
it seems real.
I wasn't real.
I don't want to go into the Strip club and have them be able to get naked like
that.
I want them to like take nervous about off.
Oh what the real miss.
I want to see like the sock marks in their leg.
Realness.
Oh,
sophomores.
Like I want real,
let's wrap this bitch up cause this is going to go south.
Sock mark.
So I just got back from Columbus,
Ohio and you're not allowed to be naked there.
And so all the girls had pastries,
but they would have like darker nipple looking pasty.
So it looked like they all just had really big area,
all that dark Ariel and now it's ridiculous.
You have to have a thin rubber sheet over the outside of your nipple and if you
go outside you could just take her shirt off cause it's legal in Columbus,
Ohio to just take your shirt off outside.
But when you're inside at the Strip club,
you have to put page.
These are in Columbus.
It's legal to be topless if you're a woman,
been there for forever.
It's,
you can just walk around with nuts.
It's hilarious.
What a dumb business.
Hey,
are you upset at all?
The freedom that you have with girl's nipples out there on the street will come
on inside.
Come on and shout.
We'll show you a watered down version of what's available right outside our
door.
Christy tickets a nipple warrior.
Who's that?
I don't know.
I just read it the other way.
She's a nipple warrior.
What does that mean?
I don't even know.
Fuck Debbie Morris kids.
That nipple warrior,
the Nipple Warriors.
Does that mean they liked?
They want everyone to be able to see their nipples.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Like I'll really sheer shirt or something like that.
No,
no,
no.
They want to go if you,
if we
just start typing Demi Moore's kid.
She just walks around shirtless.
A Barb,
you gotta be like 20 or something.
You're talking about Jay Leno.
You can,
I know
something.
One of the names,
right or something.
Wait rain or something.
Wrinkles.
More than fucking what are the more kids?
The more time and Roger Moore,
whatever his fucking on.
You're going more and more demi Moore's fucking how long time Joe?
What?
Like five minutes now her name is rumor.
Rumor,
more type in river.
More uh,
a nipple.
Don't Jay Leno.
He's a little kid alone.
No,
it's a fucking grown up.
It's a real grownup type of,
yeah.
That's rap.
James Burke Christ.
You Ladies and gentlemen,
give it up for Bert.
Kreischer.
I'll be at the Irvine Improv all weekend.
Will you be whereby the Improv style,
that fucking place is the bomb.
Diggity Irvine Improv.
The new one.
It's like a 500 seat or that place is awesome.
It's the Shit Brian Red band got anything coming up.
A Wednesday,
a secret show at the comedy store,
uh,
with Henry Phillips,
Tony Hinchcliffe in a bunch of other people.
Uh,
and I've been sure,
uh,
December 26
out standing,
uh,
Wednesday we're doing a show at the ice house.
It's a magical Greg Fitzsimmons and Tony Hinchcliffe would be there as well.
And,
uh,
Vegas December 11.
So all that shit's on Joe Rogan.
Dot Net forward slash tour.
Bert Kreischer,
ladies and gentlemen.
Yes.
Goodnight Buddy.
Okay.